and it's it's just and then i have all
this extra tissue down here separate
from the pec
yeah and my my nipples are like you know
yeah so my pec muscles right here these
are like diamonds
oh i see what you're saying so that's
hard right that's like a big old coin
here nick it's like a mask yeah you go
feel this
that's interesting yeah the squeeze
harder yeah
look how much smaller it is on my right
can you get rid of that can you take it
off you can get
you can get surgery for it right my
nipples have always been poofy
this is one of the reasons why i've been
self-conscious my whole life in five
four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast
i got my black shoes on with an
all-white shirt people look at me like i
look
like dirt hit him with it i what was it
i forget them fools i ate no food
i ride all my 20 foes on my way to
school yeah
dog you have any idea how much i
listened to that to know the lyrics oh
yeah i was just about to say that i was
like you know that pretty well yeah
bro you know how it is that's what
happens bro when i used to record music
i know
every single line of every single one of
my friends songs damn you're a good ass
friend
only because i have to sit there and
edit it
i thought you were listening to anything
that good all of a sudden they made us
kind of like all right somebody's hip
nah but
i feel you on that what's the most
awkward thing is when uh
i'll meet a person who admires me
right and they go hey man i'm a musician
like can you listen to my stuff
and then i'll be like yeah i'll listen
to it later no i got it right here i'm
like
dog please don't do this to me i listen
to it it's the worst thing i've ever
heard in my life and then they ask like
what do you think
david you know david can't lie hey keep
it if there was a gun to his head and
he's
somebody said hey you have to lie to
this person or i'm going to shoot you in
the face
i might have to his shot the face gets
shot in the face bro probably the worst
thing i
i mean it's because i think i have a lot
of leeway because they know that i you
know i climb on people a lot i joke
around a lot so i can say what i can say
versus uh like an actual youtube
musician they won't be able to say the
things that i say because i i just [ __ ]
around all the time but there's one kid
he uh
he was so aggressive with it and this
will just literally put the song to my
ear like this
so i'm just like i'm like okay okay okay
and this was out of college
and then i just put my hand on his
shoulder i was like hey man stay in
school bro
yeah yeah that's all i said you gotta
say uh just stay in school man
do you think he picked up on that or do
you think he was like you know i got a
shot
i i don't know i think well you have to
understand that
for that person to be that confident to
put that [ __ ] phone next to my
earlobe
for three minutes straight he thought he
was really really good
and also it's because his friends around
him are gassing him up like yo man you
actually not that bad
but what i gotta ask these kids is like
would you listen that [ __ ] on the radio
if not the person's not [ __ ] good
very simple i think i had that once so
we had like a
little group called sky crew right that
was like our rap group you got that
tatted on you right i got on my back
crazy yeah you're crazy yeah is sky crew
still going no i sky crew to the death
of me
you know what it'd be um but so i was at
a panda express
and i'm just sitting there waiting in my
food and so i guess one of the kids
recognized me
he's like hey because my old rap name
was moony he's like aren't you
moony like ceo of sky crew ceo i was
like
yeah i was a cfo though who's the ceo
all right
my shout out my boy teddy all right bro
tree frog
trees never rap but he was around there
were recorded
so this kid he's like oh you're he's
like bro do you think i can join the
group
damn like that yeah and i was like i
mean we
don't then you guys jumped him in at the
[ __ ] top of my thumbs up like this he
knew it was on i was like
um no so i'm a i was i just almost like
we don't really like
you know it's just like homies like if
you're a homie like you can be part of
it
he's like all right well here here's
some of my music and go and like let me
know i was like
all right then i'm just waiting for my
food you know my brother's trying to eat
[ __ ]
i thought he was gonna play music off
his phone he starts playing a beat
in the middle of panic
all loud and [ __ ] i'm just like so it
was fire on my brother the pandas
they're like
i'm like nah don't bring he started
performing performing right in front of
me
and i'm sitting there like oh my god and
you know that's like that's a tough
place to put you in and you see the you
see like the people on like they do it
for these big artists they wrap like
eight bars for maybe like a three minute
song
i'm just like dude you don't gotta do
the full start is [ __ ] seeing the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
it's like hey when i do this say i'm
like
bro they're come on the [ __ ] out of the
restaurant
no soliciting here that's the only time
i ever had it he got that pencil started
doing the desk beating [ __ ]
dude it was it was so funny
everybody did that beat at lunch you
trying to rap right now with lucky i got
you bro with the fist
and then the pencil in one hand and they
can never do it soft too it's never
it's and you see your [ __ ]
your ballpoint ped just rattle off on
the side
your boy just got myself a deadline
man my [ __ ] dead
i remember high school the [ __ ]
teachers used to hate that [ __ ] dude
there's one i forgot his name but he's
one light-skinned dude he would always
do that [ __ ] beat
and this other dude i don't even
remember their [ __ ] names but i know
they dropped out that year
obviously but these [ __ ] would
always before class would start just the
same beat
were they any good though huh were they
any good they were terrible
i remember when it evolved though
because like and then instead of the
pencil they used to use the pens and
they used to go
like like that scratch
okay evolving evolving there were so
many dudes that we would like go to
school with that
that like thought they were really good
at beatboxing and they would just do it
like unsolicited they would just be like
yo let me beat boxer quick
let me let me drop a beat and everyone's
like nobody asked for that
we didn't ask you that nobody's rapping
here really yeah we're gonna rap right
now we're trying to play some halo dude
like
you gotta take that [ __ ] outside man
they get all into it too like
you're like oh my gosh it was nasty they
were [ __ ] beatboxing their hand to be
like that she was tight now get your
hands away
bro your hands just all spit right now
dude
it's so wet bro it looks like [ __ ]
handsome i do that [ __ ] pretty good
though i remember watching this one tv
show and this guy could like do 30
instruments with his mouth at one time
and like they put him like in like a
hallway like a little like kind of
hallway sort of thing so i had like a
good job no no just i saw it on youtube
oh i thought it was somebody that just
knows
that yeah it was a guy panda express
yeah yeah i mean
but no it was crazy because like they
didn't show him
they just showed like a uh a video right
and it sounded like a full orchestra
that's crazy and they went downstairs
and it was him just doing it with his
mouth i was like holy [ __ ] police
academy who's that guy
oh i forgot his name dude not winslow is
it no
no winslow last name winslow i think
that was his name in the movie
yeah but his he would do the winslow no
way that that's what his name is no
that's family matters you dumb [ __ ]
no that's the guy from die hard bro
that's the cop from die hard so you're
dumb bro okay
yes i am dude carl winslet is it wait
what's what's his name from
valley matters
oh that's the real actors names that's
the tripping right i think that [ __ ]
just got cancelled
no lie what because i was when i you
know when i was you know taking care
of winslow because he is gay i think
carl winslow known for family matters
oh that's the show i'm dumb as [ __ ] of
course this [ __ ] canceled a long time
ago
i didn't say it i was like let's back up
right now yo
michael winslow michael winslow is the
uh sound effect guy yeah carl winslow's
family medicine yeah yeah yeah yeah so i
was close so you're still a dumb [ __ ]
yeah
there's still a piece of [ __ ] go [ __ ]
modern family is the one i'm talking
about that's okay
yeah didn't that show just get canceled
did you talk about that 90 sit combo
that she's been going on for 30 years
yeah i was in the coma so like i joe
woke up so
all these
is what happened this morning i'm sorry
dude i'm gonna call this fool out every
time let me just let me just paint a
picture once again
great it is a hot hot light today
it's a hot late today we are training in
this place the underground shadows
called akko's
garage shout out shout out to ako harbor
man
akko's warriors garage so somebody's
contact pops out of their eyes right it
was alex
and it falls right onto the floor a
dirty floor mind you by the way
it's fire outside ash everywhere
everything is on everybody
don't act like akko don't clean the map
bro i know but blisters this is
blood everywhere this is mid workout it
was like 15 minutes
bro come on shoes and [ __ ] all over 15
minutes in pat had like these boxing
shoes that fell apart he had a [ __ ]
tape it up he had boxing not even full
shoes
dirty floor the dirtiest floor i've ever
seen in my life it's not that dirty
alex's contact
pops out right now there has to be a
solution because my man's over here
sparring
but his contact pops out then over to
the left of me i hear nick say
hey just put it in your mouth and stick
it in your eye
i never said stick it in your eyes okay
i look to my left and i'm like
nick that's a funny joke i'm laughing
i'm like and my face is like this
i go and i look at him stone gold
straight dead serious
he was not making a joke do you do that
bro you get pinkie pie once and you're
fine
i've seen him do it and this is how you
know you're serious guys
i was like hey yo no i got contact
solution no just put it in your mouth
and put it back in i'm like but i got
the actual solution no that's a fit bro
i didn't know
you said it bro and then i was like oh
wait never mind that's what i said he
was like no my spit is better put it in
my mouth yeah
spit in my mouth i mean throw this in my
mouth
so this is this is okay this is old
school because obviously this is the
dirtiest [ __ ] ever it's gross it's
disgusting i know
but desperate times calls for desperate
measures okay
so back in the day we weren't here
i didn't know that until afterwards so
go [ __ ] yourself i got this close to you
okay uh my old coach martin who's
actually
like akko's long-time training partner i
remember back in the day where we were
trained this was back in like 2013
2014 contact fell out of my eye and
my man martin goes hey man just just put
in your mouth and just put it back in
your eye it'll be fine it'll be better
than if you just put in your eye
like that so that's the story and now
we're just going to put water on it it's
better than putting in your but at the
same time it's like you're in the middle
of the round
you don't want to leave and do all that
[ __ ] you just got to put it back in and
get right back on it imagine you have
that dry
like white sticky you know white like
like mustard mouse
hey bro you need to drink water if
that's the case and you put it in your
mouth like you're literally just making
it
white you know what i mean i don't know
nick you were kickboxing hitting pads
last week and you were throwing up quite
a lot
this guy this guy over here is kicking
pants and he just all i hear is
that what the [ __ ] is going on did you
throw up last week
no i didn't really i wasn't using this
it was on the launch it was on the brink
like every single time
at the wedding at the wedding on sunday
i was like
every like no before i was like nervous
i was just nervous okay
what are you nervous about there's
nobody there i know but it's still like
this is like a
this is like a and you've been with tiff
for how long
it got me 11 years in january how many
people were at your oh that's right
congratulations nick got married thank
you thank you thank you look at him dude
he's finally a grown-ass man putting
[ __ ] dirty contacts in his eyes i
know bro
is that why i have pink does tiff know
you do that yeah just let's not talk
about it
when people actually address it or like
talk about it you're like yeah that is
[ __ ]
gross [ __ ] cause that's something i
would just do like in in a pinch
it's it's gross i know it's disgusting
there was no pinch
i know but this one yeah this whole
gives me [ __ ] for eating skin on a mango
the contact falls on dirty ass floor he
puts it in his mouth and puts it back in
my second rule bro you got to put it in
and just down the hatch hey germs don't
care about no five seconds
yeah so my eyes is like made out of
steel baby like what's your vision like
it's bad it's really bad come on still
it's bad
the contents of the eye is like a little
wonky i'm like i'm like a negative
i'll say this if i didn't have contacts
on i wouldn't be able to make out like
this
like distinction how far does your hand
have to be to be involved
i'll literally have to be like this this
is how close i have to be to like
see details so you were like me that my
eyes were like my eyes are terrible i
always thought my eyes were bad until
you guys are like mine's negative twelve
oh my god have you seen
that have you seen my glasses bro
they're coke bottles why don't you get a
lasik
i'm thinking about it yeah but then you
know i won't be able to put those
contacts back in my mouth
all of us got i think so bart and i got
it me i got it
[ __ ] tiff has it everybody that we
know has a tiff like tips here
no no not tiffany and then uh gina gina
has it too everybody got lasik man you
guys got a group deal on it or what [ __ ]
i think they did i think they did a
brand deal for it i think they gotta buy
one get one free or something yeah
i don't know damn it does it hurt uh so
i had a very weird situation i don't
know what the [ __ ] happened but
so i had um i think it was called icl so
i get a permanent lens in my eye
and then i had lasik on top of it that's
how bad my eyes are so
typically what happens is after that you
get like valium or some type of you know
medication to help you fall asleep and
just help with the pain
but essentially what's happening is that
they're cutting open your eye and
they're replacing the lens and they put
a new one in and then lasik
um evens out the uneven surface of your
cornea or
people some some lasik doctors like yo
shut the [ __ ] up right now bro that
sounds legit to me yeah but that's
that's what it was an optometrist or
whatever the procedure was like 30
minutes it's super fast i think lasik
was like maybe 10 or 15. it's
that [ __ ] quick yo i want to get some
lasik yo it's it's you're awake too
so do you have to get the other stuff
done if you have like if your eyes are
bad it depends they're gonna check you
out
so if you could just get lasik you'll
just get lasik they told me because i
just got my eyes checked finally i got
contacts
i guess i'm starting to get a stigmatism
in my left eye
but this eye i've told you guys remember
i told you like this is a i have a lazy
eye in this one not in the sense of like
a wandering eye but this eye just tends
to be a lot more shut
isn't the eyelid than my right yeah so
like i'll be sitting like on my phone
and [ __ ] or just even just
somewhere and my whole left eye is just
completely closed and i just don't
notice it i don't notice this so i have
to open it up
so she had she had told me that because
this this was the first time
when i was doing that thing and like it
would take a while for it to focus i'm
like damn my eyes getting bad
i have astigmatism too i think i had a
very severe one on both eyes so you
could still get lasik with
i had to get to that that was what i was
going to do but they said that if you
are
going to get a group deal i'm not sure
if that's how it worked but
but i think like if you want to get into
combat fighting like if you still want
to spar
you should you have you should do the
ico yeah that's what i heard too i heard
lasik you can't do it like you can't
fight
am i tripping i heard that you're like
in the ufc or something you can't have
that
i think it's a certain type of uh yeah
like you're not allowed to have a
specific type of
eye surgery yeah because i heard
somebody told me this i forgot who it
was it was a fighter i forgot what we
were talking to but they said
if you scratch the lens if you get
certain lasik you won't be able to see
anymore
yeah you'll be [ __ ] yeah so i think
you do have to get a special i think
that's the kind that you got yeah
because bart had that too and i to get
that [ __ ] yeah yeah so i i think it'll
be fine do you remember what your number
was before like the negative it's like
negative 10 negative 11. it was god damn
isn't that legally blind yeah i was like
legally but
i'm negative like if i fell asleep with
my glass you know like when you fall
asleep with your glasses and the next
day they just happen to disappear to
another universe
you don't know where the [ __ ] it is and
then when you do fight it the [ __ ]
yeah you put them on there like this
[ __ ]
you know that's that's glasses problems
so i remember i would fall asleep with
my glasses on and i wake up and they're
not on my face and then i'm completely
[ __ ]
one time i didn't leave the house the
whole day because i couldn't find my
glasses
and by the time it got dark i was
completely [ __ ] bro imagine david like
now i know your tendencies and how you
forgetful you are
so i could only imagine what you were
like when you had glasses oh i was just
blind all the time dude
bro i was like that all the time as a
kid with the glasses stuff bro
i used to go to school with like one of
the things like all the way up here yeah
bro like glasses would be so like
off-center but just enough so i could
still see and [ __ ] but when your eyes
are that bad you have very limited
options to what you can get
so i couldn't get i remember i wanted
like these uh
frameless ones and they're like listen
your eyes are way too bad for that that
[ __ ] was just
it was
[Laughter]
ones oh that [ __ ] was [ __ ] white but
after a while you get the transition
ones they start turning brown and [ __ ]
like they just stopped
about that when you go in the sun yeah
they turn their sunglasses
those went to [ __ ] everybody who had
transitioned glasses that i knew of
also got murdered for being a loser
that's
my dad bro it was old it went frameless
to like half frame remember yeah yeah
people just like the top frame hey did
you guys ever have those lanyards from
behind just uh
i did when i was when i first had
glasses because he was balling
because he was like though it was
because of basketball
i had to get that loop and tighten it up
real quick
that [ __ ] real hard to the back i also
had the horse grand plastic ones because
i was like taekwondo
so i detect my noah's because you know i
needed it for what i would spar that's
what they should make the ufc fighters
use so they'll get eyeballs
i know right those eyebrokes are so
[ __ ] bad lately dude bro that nico
price poked donald cerrone in the eyes
like
five times and he didn't get a point
taken he finally eventually did but i
was like dude that's like five [ __ ]
jokes dude holy [ __ ] that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] weird but we should talk about
trump apparently has coveted which i
don't believe
and by the way this video is going to
come out a week after all this
information is going to come out before
it so i don't give a [ __ ] what y'all
think
i'm telling you right now he does not
have coven 100 this she has fake news a
hundred percent
fake news a hundred percent because if
he has cobid first of all
he's fat as [ __ ] yeah right he's old as
[ __ ]
he got on [ __ ] bad old ass though bro
he stands like this too like i saw some
post talking about it's some disease
or you it's leading up to a disease when
they stand they're kind of leaning
forward your lumbar spine is completely
around 100
now i noticed it every time the way he
walks he reminds me of my elementary
friend darius's mom like his mom would
have kind of leaned forward and she had
a big old dumb dude
just like swaying down the halls he he
has the the walk of somebody sassy ass
auntie
i gotta show you this video because
there's a video of some meme about that
[ __ ]
i was dying so [ __ ] hard it's like
what he looks like dude that's funny
he got a fat all ass i'm like damn trump
yeah
immediately after the debate like a day
after yeah
first of all melania doesn't have coven
because she has to be human first that
[ __ ]
is a robot bro she hates him
like all these videos they're trying
he's trying to grab her hand [ __ ] she's
like not about that [ __ ] bro
bro like grab my hand she's literally
like i know i'm like she does not hide
it
she knows that everybody's watching and
she still does that [ __ ] i'm like bro
she must
hate the [ __ ] out you dude i wonder what
they're like when they
talk like that at home you know like how
how snappy she is at him like you shut
the [ __ ] up like just walks away she
probably doesn't spend time with him but
you guys saw that one video clip
where uh i forgot where he was he was
having a speech but he just flew in
because addressing the crowd he goes i
wish uh melania uh sends her best wishes
she wishes she was here
dog she's right next to her
that's so crazy she flew with him in the
private jet
and she's standing right next to him he
goes melania i wish
she was here right now bruh so that
means they're sitting
right here in right here they're playing
the whole thing [ __ ] hate each other
her uh trump winning the presidency is
probably the worst thing that ever
happened yeah
she probably was about to leave his
house that means i gotta stick with this
dude forever like for at least four
years do they have a kid together do
they
no i think he has a he has a younger son
a kid from his previous marriage
ivanka and his other little dude i
thought he had like a little one right
a little bit jeffrey jeffrey or
something kyle
ken i don't know what the [ __ ] skyler
yeah skyla
yeah i agree with you though i think
that shit's fake like i was telling you
guys
i saw some tweet someone reposted a
tweet that was posted on the 18th of
september
talking about the surprise that he has
in october
was he's going to get this so-called
virus so
he's the topic for two whole weeks right
because it's a 14-day thing you have to
watch him
then all the debates everything like
that goes out the window oh my bro
that's literally exactly what's
happening yeah it's a hundred percent
crazy because when did they make this
prediction night uh september 18th
wow if he caught covet he's gonna die
he has every single pre-existing
condition to die from kovid
so if he's going to just come out and
he'll i have a feeling he's going to say
like look i survived it exactly i'm
strong
that's a good dress thank you i survived
this while he's okay as your president
yeah it's huge it's huge it's not that
big of a deal i think
i think that's what he's going to do
because he's already he's got a doubt
playing ben's saying like well it's not
that worrisome or whatever like that
that's where he's gonna get it
he's gonna [ __ ] get in and he's gonna
[ __ ] live and he's gonna be like oh
see look i survived it's not as bad as
they're making a scene it's like because
if he has covet i wanna talk to the
doctor that was helping him out with the
whole situation and he needs to confirm
that he had coveted bro all this [ __ ] is
just going to be
all fake yeah if if if he really didn't
have it but who the [ __ ] knows anymore
like we it's just such nonsense you know
it's like you can't trust anything
anytime i hear something on the news i'm
like yeah whatever i just don't i don't
know anything about politics man it's
so the more i learn about it the less i
know that's the hard part about politics
if you don't want to learn about
politics just watch the
the debates because they talk about all
politics
like this guy's a [ __ ] clown he's
like [ __ ] you with your mother
when he called him a clown he told him
to shut up i'm like oh
coming out with their big guns they're
not even the the moderator
you know i i it seemed like he'd do the
he did the best that he could have done
yeah it seems like a broken system like
these guys aren't even talk like it's
just nonsense it's just a [ __ ]
they're just arguing i remember too like
i saw people like
matt trump supporters mad about biden
telling him oh you just shut up look how
he's talking i'm like
do you guys not remember when he was
talking to hillary yeah in their debates
and that was fine but now someone calls
them a clown and tells them to shut up
everybody's [ __ ] butts hurt yeah i'm
like you guys are insane
all they need to do is wait five more
minutes and he's going to say something
he was bad right it was so weird because
he just wouldn't stop talking over him
and it got to the point well it's weird
because like biden is in a lose-lose
situation right if he lets him talk over
him he looks weak
yeah if he if he speaks up and he starts
going until that he looks immature so i
don't know
i don't know [ __ ] about politics all i
know is that i'm probably gonna have to
vote for biden
yeah one of my clients was like yo this
motherfucker's on adderall like he's
he's just super focused talking about
biden because he just the whole time
at first i was like man this is gonna be
bad for him because after hearing him
talk about the little hairs on the legs
you saw that you ever seen that clip
where he's at like a pool or some [ __ ]
and he starts talking about
like how he used to like work with
little like it's so
incoherent like it's you don't know what
the [ __ ] he's saying he's like
the kids would touch the hairs on my
legs
and they would say wow like it was
literally like that
and he's everyone's looking at him like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about he
had brain surgery though he had it
twice oh two times yeah he i think he
had like a brain in here with sleepy joe
man
that's like the best [ __ ] nickname
that trump has everything that's bro
that's such a good that's so catchy
probably roasted people though
when you watch the debates you're like
yo trump's funny dog like say what you
will about him he has good comedy timing
like the way he shits on biden
whether you like him or not he's a kobe
covington dude he's funny bro
yeah he's funny covington dude that's
why
that's why colby covington was so hyped
when he got that phone call oh of course
mr president i'm like yo put your dick
back in your pants yeah
shut the [ __ ] up yeah dude that [ __ ] was
and like
the moment i shook your hand you gave me
dragon energy no i [ __ ] got a girl
i'm like dude how are you like i
understand he's doing it but like how
are you not embarra like
because you know that wasn't part of
script like he was for real you know
he's a
weeb at heart he's a dweeb that's what
it is he's a [ __ ] dork bro you know
but just don't beat me up i'm not he'll
still beat the [ __ ] out of people but
still bro
i gave you saw gay
he's like at the trump thing he was so
nice and all this [ __ ] he's like and
then
a couple days later i see him on these
interviews talking all the [ __ ] he's
like
i probably he's like i despise this guy
more than most in the world he's like
aside from like pedophiles and [ __ ]
i was like damn great she hates this
[ __ ] because apple's a real ass
dude bro
like he's about that life so if you
start talking [ __ ] like especially if
you're being cool and they all have well
they're not actually
the same management company but like
they were all hanging out together so
it's like the fact that he was
talking [ __ ] about him afterwards was
like why yeah you guys have the same
division you know
i think he [ __ ] kills that man yeah i
think so too because he's talking about
pressure and then uh what's it called uh
[ __ ] uh what's the word i'm looking
for when you last really long
stamina endurance and doors
indoors you got that [ __ ] he got the
endurance yeah
i just don't know what trouble he would
give him yeah i don't think so
that's funny when you say like indeed
bullets don't discriminate for some
reason gave me a round thought back in
the day when you know he was rying and
[ __ ] bro
like we were talking about this one
thing and this one guys to my our friend
smokey g that's what we used to call
smokey
what was his position in sky crew each
is a rapper bro
yeah he was from kansas city he's an
emotional healer where he's at right now
could not tell you bro the last time
what do you think he's doing
what do you think he's doing now not
good stuff like that
let's talk about like pyramid schemes
selling drugs what are we talking about
it's drugs but i don't think he's
selling them he's doing like from
towards the end like when we stop seeing
him because that fool just kind of like
disappeared
like he we did we stopped like it was it
was it was hella weird but
uh we were talking about one time and
someone told him he's like
man that fool beat your ass he's like oh
no he's like man i phone knock your ass
out he's like
bet you he won't knock out this 9
millimeter though
alrighty we were just trying to have
some fun
you're like i think you're right that
[ __ ] reminded me did nobody have a
regular name
was it like there was like smokey g tree
frog and there was just
peter no like part of the resonator
to compliment all those names uh no it
was we didn't
well we all had our nicknames but i
hated my rap name mooney
give david a rap name right now d
just d bro and then what about me
what about what about pat p hey what
about
hey no no he can't be a because i'm a i
feel like akko's already a name
there's already a name yeah that's true
yeah that's true his real name is
i think oh really that's even better
that [ __ ] goes hard bro that's
that's one of the best dudes ever so
when we went to corner
heinrich in guadalajara um say it better
though
guadalajara there you go
so literally married to a hispanic lady
so here's pronouncement yeah you're
right my bad my fault my fault sorry
babe
um so we go to the airport at lax
they hold akko at customs for a while
because they didn't believe that
micronesia which is where he's from
was a real place that's [ __ ] funny
they had to google it
right so they got they got delayed from
leaving lax to guadalajara when we left
guadalajara
back to lax we were stuck at customs for
like
an hour because he got held at lax yeah
because they didn't think bro oh i
thought you meant they held them and no
that happened again
they had to google it they had they were
like they weren't sure they were looking
at his passport they're like this ain't
real
they didn't think the micronesian
password that's hilarious
and we're like what the [ __ ] is going on
i could understand in guadalajara yeah
but out here bro like that's crazy i
thought it was the other way around like
the whole time i knew that story like no
offense
like i'm not saying airport workers are
dumb because that's not all true but
there's a lot of funny stories where
like [ __ ] slips through the cracks yeah
there's some terrible workers there for
example
uh joe told me the story where bart and
joe were
uh i think it was a layover in detroit
right
and so this podcast is brought to you by
skillshare my friends i don't know you
but you look like a person who has some
talent or hobby that you are dying to
explore
but you don't even know where to start
it could be graphic design
photography music production filmmaking
you name it skillshare has the courses
for you
this is not a textbook traditional
learning environment you are going to
learn the way that you want to and the
way that i want to
which is interactively through videos
however i want and whenever i want and
stop scrolling through the web hunting
for information when you got all the
courses you need on skillshare
my favorite course that i use right now
is actually filmmaking from home that
teaches me how to use found footage to
make a compelling
video it helps out a lot of my videos
and you'll actually see me use it in the
videos that i use
now i'm always learning new things to
make of my videos to make up my videos
i'm going to tell you and make up my
videos to make my videos better
and this course is dope explore your
creativity at skillshare.comgb and the
first thousand people to use our link
will get a free trial of skillshare
premium membership receive free access
to thousands of classes for a limited
time
be one of the first thousand to sign up
at skillshare.com they get to their gate
and i might be slaughtering the story
but i don't give a [ __ ]
listen to like what yeah they get to
their gate and something happens along
the lines of
they show up 15 minutes before their
flight is supposed to leave like before
their departure time
right and they get in they're like oh
sorry sir you can't you can't get on the
plane because
you guys are here you're not here on
time and he goes
no we're here 15 minutes before
departure the plane's right there they
go yeah but your flight leaves at 11.
like we know we're here at 10 45 yeah
and they go sir
grab their ticket it says 11 o'clock
and bart and joe are confused i don't
know what the number exactly is but it's
something along those lines he says
45 he goes yeah we're here 15 minutes
before the
departure time so we we're here
we're not even boarding and they're
rolling their eyes like they're dumb
they go
sir 11 o'clock your flight it leaves he
goes
we know we're here can we speak to your
manager
and the manager comes over and they go
what's the problem he goes well they're
not letting us on the plane
and we're here 15 minutes before the
departure time and the matter
goes yeah start on your ticket it says
11.
oh no that's how [ __ ] dumb some
people are
they're [ __ ] dumb this is at tsa
this is this is at their gate so these
are the flight attendants that are
whatever you know yeah they're either
going to go on the fight or whatever
what not
and they're like the plane is there
we're here before our time so
we're allowed to go on yeah no sir it
says 11 o'clock like
it's like [ __ ] it's 10 45. i know i'm
here the plane is still
there people are still boarding can i go
on please it's [ __ ] ridiculous so
like they
they didn't know what to say because you
can't rationalize that conversation with
a dumb person
and if you go too hard then they'll kick
you out yeah you won't be able to
[ __ ] fly
mad at you for some [ __ ] right yeah
you have the flu
oh yeah you're going to sacramento what
the [ __ ] happened i i i just
he david tried to fight the [ __ ]
flight attendant hey david's hands
weren't like this he was like what
are you doing oh so what happened was
now i remember it was because they
they [ __ ] up my flight they they i
booked it and i showed them where i
booked it but they put me on another
flight that was two hours later or some
[ __ ] like that i don't remember the
specifics anymore because i was so
[ __ ] pissed
but i was upset and what i said was i
remember you were clearly in the right
i was in the right because they [ __ ]
up exactly so i i actually put like a
whole [ __ ] thing and i sent it to
southwest and they apologized and they
refunded but i feel like i remember this
like you posted about i was [ __ ]
furious so what happened with that
situation
uh i they basically [ __ ] up my flight
twice
so i booked it once and it was [ __ ] up
and i asked them to rebook it because i
caught it before
and they [ __ ] up the booking again and
then i
i was like i'm already here at the
airport i'm i'm going on
holiday like i have to like can we fix
the situation
and they're like oh they couldn't figure
out and i was like dude this is this
situation is [ __ ] up and this lady
looks
and this guy comes out of nowhere not
even the attendant and he goes sir you
need to watch your mouth and i'm like
excuse me you know what i mean he ran up
to you like this too yeah and it was
this
it was a big old dude he was like you
need to watch your mouth i'll kick you
out of this airport and i was like
you're gonna kick me out of this airport
for something you guys [ __ ] up
on i was like i'm not even upset and i'm
not even talking to you yeah i was like
i didn't curse at the lady
i just said that this situation is
[ __ ] up i wasn't mad i'm mad now
yeah you know cause you're trying to
threaten me yeah he goes he's a tough
guy
and he looked at me and he said to quote
him he goes i'll make sure that you
won't go see your family for the
holidays and i looked at him that's rude
as [ __ ]
and i just looked at him and i was like
cool what's your name my boy's power
tripping and i looked and was like
what's your name it's like cool
as i'm talking to him i'm over here just
like typing in the complaint i open up
everything and they're finding me the
flight i was like cool
looking at him and he just looks at me
and he just walks away and i'm like dog
you're saying this because you have this
small amount of power
and you're using it over here sock this
dude in the face
i should be fired for saying something
like that i literally wrote the whole
situation down i'm like i'm at the
airport right now
you need to fire this employee yeah like
he threatened me saying that i couldn't
leave home for a mistake that you guys
made twice and i wasn't even that happy
he wasn't even there so he doesn't even
know what the [ __ ] is going on so what
i'm thinking is
worry about your own [ __ ] line my guy
like exactly it's like what the [ __ ] is
your problem
like i wasn't even mad at her and i
looked at him and i was like oh sorry it
wasn't hurt it was a it was a gay dude
my bad apologies but i looked at him i
was like
were you threatened like did i did i say
anything he was like no it's okay and
i'm like
the [ __ ] is with this guy like what the
hell yeah he just kind of came out of
nowhere
and he wanted to belittle him he didn't
even work there and he was like
thank you he gets his suitcase he said
he goes onto his floor
i told that guy off back there yeah that
[ __ ] pissed me off that's dope
what a cool guy
what's his name i can't remember i look
at the southwest thing but
they refunded my whole flight and
everything even after i got on the
flight and that's why i don't fly bro
you scared of flying huh hell yeah i'm
scared wait how was your flight you i
remember you went to
i went to seattle right when seattle was
the hotbed right when kovitz started
yeah it was like
the week before because i came the
mirror i came back the weekend that's
right we did the parking yourself for a
bit yeah
i did i quarantined myself for two weeks
and then everybody got out of here
they're like
yeah because i was having a [ __ ]
allergy attack and they were everyone
commented on like he asked kobe it would
i'm like bro and he did it was crazy i
did i gave it to them
gave it to the trunk
i [ __ ] you know i grabbed trump like
this his life
[Laughter]
rolling the dick and then you had your
[ __ ] little grip around his waist i
was like bro
you barely had your fingers locked i was
like this i was like
i had i had both my hands around his
hips and i was like [ __ ]
i was trying to close the gap but i grew
up nick like i'm so tired i'm tapping
out he didn't even [ __ ] get off me
bro never seen somebody just roll for
five minutes ago
hey this [ __ ] always does this
[ __ ] he'd be pulling some sandbaggy [ __ ]
so i'm like dog just
like i'm not trying to [ __ ] you up i'm
teaching him how to do where you know
he's like i'm not trying to [ __ ] you up
bro yeah i was dropping elbows on his
[ __ ] bro
exhausted bro i know but you got to keep
moving who cares
i'm [ __ ] 255 bro so what damn you're
255.
what's wrong with you man yeah i'm
living good
hey i'm still getting solid though he
thick look hey so the heaviest i got
though was 2
258 so i'm good three pounds away
no no and that was a 255 after eating
dog i could pee and go down three pounds
what the [ __ ] are you talking about well
i i just
i had eaten dinner we were watching the
fights last weekend had eaten dinner
whatever like that and i went into my
boy's bathroom
and he just had the scale there i was
like [ __ ] let me get naked right quick
so i got naked and i snapped down
the door the [ __ ] are you doing pooping
255 bro i was like all right so i'm just
gonna use that number because i know i
just ate
and all that type of [ __ ] i'm probably
not 255 exactly it's hard to be losing
weight when you don't give a [ __ ] man
i don't it's hard to lose weight when
the gyms aren't open bro like i know i
can go outside and do all this park [ __ ]
and stuff but
that's what i do [ __ ] jerk [ __ ] bro
no cuz i need a lift heavy weight
you know you're weak i'm strong i'm
killing like a 15 pound kettlebell like
man i'm tired
i'm about to go yeah bro i need to start
working out more i'm about to start
going just like yeah or just start
walking like we talked about probably
regular watching it's boring bro dog put
a dog
i'm gonna put on genius yeah i'm saying
put it on that genius brains
like i can walk i don't know it's the
most underrated [ __ ]
way to lose get some activity if there
was people with me i could be better if
walking's boring just ride a bike i'd
just be riding the bike so i want to buy
a bike
get every time i want to buy something
nick says no for like three weeks and
then he's like all right do it
i was like bro don't even live dude what
about the bike
yeah you told me no you said don't get a
bike nothing said that you did you're
like
why would i tell you not to get a bike
bro just start walking bro your hands
are like this too yeah yeah
yeah your hands are like this to throw
them against eyes when you're just start
walking my hands are all stupid when i
talk to you
but are you still riding your bike or no
well not because it's [ __ ] fire
because yeah
so he's got a new fire on the way over
here yeah there's another fire
literally right next to my office it's
right above my house kind of like when i
drove up
allen you could see it and it's directly
over us yeah because when i when i
started ride the bike even after the
the initial fire went away like my
throat was hurting just coughing up
all ash bro i can't i can't lie to you
there was a time during that
like i was like [ __ ] am i getting sick
when all that ash was going but i was
like no because
once i went and bought that air filter
from my room like immediately felt
better because i was breathing in like
clean air and [ __ ] dude but that when
the fires we had
i'm sure everybody seen it the people
did the [ __ ] uh
gender reveal started the [ __ ] fire
in san gabriel where i'm
at in the morning was so bad dude
like go outside you can't see [ __ ] it
was just straight
like foggy and the smell was so much
dude
it just like some points i felt like i
couldn't even breathe in my own room
like if i was sitting there like
straight up taking a [ __ ] in the
bathroom i'm like
oh [ __ ] i can't breathe dude and like my
lungs were hurting and all this type of
[ __ ]
you'd be all wheezy at the end of the
wheezy yeah and then you're like
you know when you have like a raspy
voice and [ __ ] you're like dude what the
[ __ ] start becoming a blues musician
[Laughter]
you hear that
no but that [ __ ] was crazy dude and that
was another one i knew it i knew there
was something going on because
i was telling david earlier when i woke
up this morning i thought i smelled
smoke
yeah i was like it smells smoky again
but just like randomly
smoked do we have any new info on this
new fire i have no idea bro i
just saw like when i was talking about
it when i looked yeah because i was so
excited
i was so excited about today bro i was
so excited about today i came here a
whole hour early
so like i saw the fire because i came
here a whole hour early though
you know it's funny when we left aqua's
house after we trained
i'm talking to just david and then i'm
like all right hey i was like hey what's
he was like what time is it
3 50 and i was like all right well and
he goes uh let's just
let's just do it at six instead of five
and i'm like all right cool sounds good
we left and then as i'm cleaning the
house around like 5 30
i'm like [ __ ] i wonder if alex is there
because we know
we did not talk to him about
not today though like when went to
akko's i was purposely late because i
knew
i knew someone was going to be late bro
come on dog
like see my hand this means i stirring
with that you're taking the page out of
the old david sober
hey bro i got i'm coming from temple
city i'm trying bro temple city royal
city
i eat their own but deep in temple city
my guy like i used to live in temple
city
where what street golden west in las
tunis baby his house is below that
like below that because you can't go
that much below because it turns into um
yeah exactly so it's pretty much in
downing out here i'm driving from the
maps
and i also have the smallest car of all
time so it takes me longer to drive
up so but no as i was driving here i
noticed the smoke
and i was like what the [ __ ] i was like
damn there's another [ __ ] fire i
can't believe this [ __ ]
that's just nuts man but you know what
people want stuff we want they want to
talk about [ __ ]
israel
i danny want to say i called it acidenia
all day
i believe i thought it was going to be a
little more competitive
i didn't think it was going to be a
complete shutout like
that's a 7-0 skunk right there bro it
was bad dude that was one of the worst
title fights
it just shows how high level israel is
and then you you could make the case
that
apollo kind of you know want to say
the human trash the human trash
that was the worst instagram story he
could have ever done he goes
now i'm ready i was like bro you're
ready
you already fought you lost your shot my
guy like
at least for a little bit my prediction
was wrong but
my my what i said was going to happen
right
so i thought paulo costa could pull it
off and so i chose i was like you know
what
i think paulo takes his fight and then i
even said
but if he don't he's about to just get
his ass [ __ ] pieced up
not with those calf kicks he might not
do that's exactly what happened
saw those little [ __ ] cupping marks
and he goes that's where i'm going
and he only hit that calf and above the
knee consistently didn't hit the thigh
nothing else it was
bad it was masterful bro like it just
shows how
intelligent he is and how able how well
he's able to control a fighter like
paula costa
keep his range keep his distance and
just pick him apart like that was
insane just managing that distance i
couldn't believe it i couldn't believe
it i was like
whoa i could believe it but at the same
time i was like i just did not think it
was gonna happen this way
that easy yeah he made it look so easy
bro he took like i think i saw the
numbers he got hit
12 times yeah bro and it's like all like
body kicks yeah
like little [ __ ] he was still catching
it you know like it still
landed but technically not with the
desired effect that he was hoping for
and like a guy like costa bro he runs
through everybody the fact that he had a
fight like that
he went toe-to-toe with yo romero and
just
you know went to town on each other i
mean it's really true though because
when they when you know when fighters
like
uh ottawa is talking about it he goes
you're saying i don't have power like i
don't need power i need precision
because it's about those hits that you
don't see it's the iq bro yeah he has
such
high fight iq yeah and he displayed it
that's why he's it's the same [ __ ]
connor said he was like precision
overpowered yeah and he gets hit with
these
strikes that you don't see coming and it
knocks you out and that's what happened
to [ __ ] costa he froze
and whitaker oh and whitaker yeah he
froze them dude mm-hmm
like at least whitaker through that's
the only thing cause like now there's
speculation or he's saying because they
released footage of
costa with his knee like [ __ ] almost
in a cast when he was training and [ __ ]
they're saying that he was injured but
he doesn't want to talk about it but
other people are
i could see if that was the case i could
see why he wasn't running in
but also he could have not been running
in because
he knows how good [ __ ] izzy is at
striking so once you run in
and you're just leaving so much more
openings and uriah hall was able to
[ __ ]
jab him up and uh from running in all
these people were able to do that [ __ ]
costa has some big holes in his game
like he's not like
like the best striker you know i mean
but like he makes up for it for being
very tenacious he's a big strong
physical guy and he's able to push the
pace and keep that clip
over three rounds at least so that's
when it's like all right well he
presents a whole different
amount of problems it's hard though
because it i just started dying laughing
when uh
because you know they always had those
mma channels and they put up kosta tells
the reason why he didn't perform well
it was i didn't sleep well yeah that's
what he said
yes i was like bro did you just put this
whole hype about what we wanted to hear
you guys i'll finally tell you
last night i know sleepy i know
i don't think some of these fighters are
ready for fight island
because i because the whole thing is
like when i was looking at the time i
was like i'm curious to see what time
these people are fighting yeah the first
fight
happened at 3 00 a.m their time bro and
it's like
they always had this problem right like
from pride like all the pride fighters
would come fight in the us
they would always like like lose you
know they wouldn't
like the japanese fighters would always
not do that well when they would fight
in the states
but when the american fighters or the
the the local fighters in the us would
go fight in japan or something like that
they would all get dusted you know i
feel like if you're gonna go fight in
another country or another time you
better stay there for a couple of weeks
yeah a couple weeks at least adjust in
the first week and then start training
in the next
and my thing is choose like you know he
probably didn't wake up
an hour before the fight you know he has
to be there for like all the media [ __ ]
and stuff like that so
that fool probably had they i think they
fought around 8 30 in the morning over
their time
so you know he's asked how to wake up
like at three or four same with reyes i
think that was the thing too i don't
think they're ready for it bro yeah but
at the same time it's like you can make
the same argument for fighters that are
prepared for it they are ready to go
yeah
that's what i'm saying so that shows it
shows how much better is he is bro yeah
he's in the same situation he's he izzy
probably didn't sleep either you still
beat your [ __ ] ass yeah i mean
everybody's in the same situation yeah
who's this i just think some people
aren't ready for it yeah they're
probably trying to talk about it oh i'll
be cool
oh i'll be cool because i was watching
this embedded and some of them like oh
i'll be fine and those same people got
their [ __ ] ass whooped right
do you they look like the show do you
think the gyno thing is for real that he
has did they use steroids
i don't so this is what i said i i know
gyno because i have gyno
right and i've seen people say like oh
you can't just get into one peck
from what we searched today and what
like me growing up
my right one started first when i was
[ __ ] like 14 years old
and then my left one came my right one's
a lot bigger than my left
um i don't think izzy's on anything
could be a [ __ ] um genetic genetic it
could be genetic
um but also it could be just some sort
of supplement he's taking
right uh it could have some side effect
in him where it's making his estrogen
build up why what what is gyno exactly
it's the gland so
gynomastia is like the glands basically
like the breast glands in a woman little
tissue yeah it's tissue so
they feel that so like if you go like
this you'll feel like a big
lump like i have like everyone at home
just do this along with us yeah so
there's a big lump so
it's like it's hard to explain it feels
like a big coin like this
under my nipple and it's it's just and
then i have all this extra tissue down
here
separate from the pec yeah and my my
nipples are like you know yeah so my pec
muscles
oh i see what you're saying so that's
hard right that's like a big old coin
here nick
look how much smaller it is than my
right can you get rid of that you take
care of you
you can get surgery for it right my
nipples have always been poofy
this is one of the reasons why i've been
self-conscious my whole life was my
[ __ ] gyno right
because i didn't know what it was when i
was growing up i was like i don't know
what the [ __ ] wrong with me everybody
else takes off their shirt they don't
got big-ass poofy nipples and all this
type of [ __ ]
right but my right one was there first
before i left
and then i've been seeing a bunch of
people say oh it doesn't just happen one
peck you get it both so i went in
like from some of those people saying if
you do your own research you know that
i'm like i just did research today and
literally said you can get it in one bag
yeah like it doesn't just both have like
you know yeah you're not just like
physiologically are you ready are you
ready i'm not ready
to stay there yeah the weirdest thing is
like when you flex you can see like the
pec and then like
the extra it's like a big lump bro like
i can push it around like this that's so
interesting
yeah it's a real idea uh but yeah it's
it's weird and
like i said i don't it could just be
natural it could just be something that
happens performance is so good whether
he let's say he was on something
don't matter he didn't win my power he
won by precision and
especially with how much they get drug
tested i'm really curious to see
especially with usada but then again
it's like
you never know you just really yeah i
mean every people have gotten caught
that you never michael phelps was on
[ __ ] he didn't look like he was on
[ __ ]
yeah steroids because i'm not sorry not
michael phelps the [ __ ] biker guy
what's his name oh lance armstrong
armstrong is the same name
a complete difference they were swimming
one was biking yeah
they didn't even sound the same i mean
um
now i can't remember he said lace he
didn't say laughs he said hey yo
like the first
as a marketing ploy and then everybody
just gave those rubber wristbands and
then
i love boobies
though dude
yup that [ __ ] didn't work on nobody
these girls were sucking dick all over
the place
let me take my band off and go off the
side what would jesus do they would take
the brand off and they would use
a [ __ ] ring and it would suck that [ __ ]
i guess
but no i i don't know i think like i
my personal opinion is i think he's
eating something
or like taking a supplement might be new
what if that fool has like breast cancer
that should be nuts
that affects like two percent in men
yeah it looks
cuz here's the thing when i've watched
izzy fight and i've seen him flex and
[ __ ] i've noticed the gyno in his pec
it's just never been this big yeah like
you can see you can see a lot of people
and
[ __ ] tj dillashaw has had gyno for a
long time bro
he got weird nips when he flexes you can
see it
they kind of stick up like a [ __ ]
titty like a nipple
um i gotta look that up you could tell
like you can really see it right
kill a shot thriller shot dillashaw yeah
bro i'm gonna show you right now
nipples dillashaw nipples
looking up some of the most yeah dude
i'm into this
nipples he got pointy ass nipples oh
it's on his left side a little bit more
huh
there's one gsp got some puffy nipples
but he don't know like low-key though
gsp he's cool and all but
you think he's on the sauce bro there's
what all of a sudden right when usada
comes in he [ __ ] leaves
you know who has gyno bad who search
josh
emmett he got a bad guy now corey
anderson
corey anderson has gyno um wow
yeah dude it's it you know it affects a
lot are you talking about josh emmett
the overhand killer josh
yes sir he has gynomastia you could see
like in this picture
you can see kind of like the big old
hard lump i was telling you
oh yeah yeah i see that you can see it's
like a big old coin like kind of hard
lump under it
and it's just from the glands growing
it's the damage this one a tj is bad
yeah bro and you can see it like it's
natural it happens to a lot of people
and uh you know it's a lot of people
that are heavyset get it too
yeah um i honestly if i'm not mistaken i
could be incorrect
but i think i remember reading a lot of
african americans get it a lot more
yeah than other races get it i read that
too um
so it's it's a normal thing and it could
just be normal
the only thing is like i know he's like
30 or 31 so for
him to hit him later i don't think he's
on [ __ ] because like you can
you can kind of tell that dude was back
in the day i think i told the story but
that guy
uh name is simeon panda he got hella mad
at me yeah because i made
because i posted a meme that somebody
else made on my instagram about his
his like pecs being like looking like
titties he got mad at you
he got mad at me this is this is like 10
years ago this is before he was huge
like before he was a big big guy or
whatever i didn't know who the [ __ ]
nobody really knew who the [ __ ] he was
yeah great name though yeah samia and
pandan so i'm like oh
stop saying you're all natural though he
said he's all natural
yeah right but anyways that guy uh
funny so i i was just posting like funny
memes on myself just like when memes
just started right
and i just posted i thought this was
[ __ ] funny and i said let's do that
lopsided titties i left it at that
that's funny and bigger and i went back
to the picture
and people are like yo sami and pen is
mad at you and they're writing lol and
i'm like who's simi and panda
and it was that guy that was on this
photo i don't even know who he was
i just posted a meme that was online
yeah it wasn't like i made the meme yeah
and the dude was [ __ ] mad and so he
starts typing to me
and he goes you're not even that funny
and i wrote i was like who are you
question mark and he goes he goes no i
just don't think you're funny like why
do you think you're funny and i wrote
back i was like
if your feelings are hurt just just say
that your feelings are hurt and i'll put
the the photo down
right and then my my followers saw that
and they started roasting this food
they're like dude you're what
you're [ __ ] buff is [ __ ] why are you
so sensitive yeah and they just started
roasting him constantly he started
fighting and arguing with all the
comments
i just wrote them i was like dude just
say that i hurt your feelings
and i'll put the photo and say my
feelings are hurt that's
this guy right here
he goes he's like he goes no he was like
if you're a comedian you're supposed to
be funny i don't think this is funny i
was like
are your feelings hurt question mark
just say
my feelings spoken embarrassing yeah i
just started writing all this [ __ ] and i
was like
block i just blocked
that's hilarious bro number one that's
funny as [ __ ] number two
stop saying you're all natural because
you're not bro he's he's gigantic
he looks like i understand when you're
at
level right you make money you have to
make money some people don't like people
that are on steroids i understand
what i can't say and i just i can't
stand the [ __ ] lying
yeps people aren't [ __ ] natural bro
he's also selling his own supplement
line yeah right and
part of it i don't know if that's part
of the marketing but i'm sure it's
implied if you haven't seen there's a
documentary called bigger stronger
faster i think that's the correct way
though i saw that uh i haven't seen it
but i saw it on uh
yes bigger i forget what it is it's a
huge thing
a lot of power lifters like you know the
power lifter big power lifter guy and
his brother made it whatever like that
but they literally go through he shows
you everything that these fitness things
go through for these pictures
big old jack guys and all this [ __ ] for
one supplement so he asked him he's like
so you really take this to guess read it
he's like yeah
he's like only this yeah well i'm also
on like some tests and oh [ __ ] it's like
so that's how fake that [ __ ] is right
bro it's because it's at the end of the
day it's like i'm trying to sell my fat
burner of course
yeah yeah if i'm trying to sell my
because if you look at the data and the
research
fat burners don't necessarily work all
that well yeah for you to be able to
lose fat you need a calorie deficit no
matter what
whether yeah if you're if you're in a
calorie deficit with your nutrition
and you're able to take a fat burner
yeah it might help a little bit
those fat burners are just like
thermogenics right they just bro it's
almost like caffeine
yeah it's a lot of it is caffeine yeah
it's like 300 milligrams of caffeine
which is a lot more
and then on top of that they also have a
couple of things here and there where
it might help a little bit but at the
same time it's like
in your mind you're taking this [ __ ]
you're like yeah i'm losing [ __ ]
weight
yeah but in reality it does obviously it
doesn't work that way because every
[ __ ] product line
has a fat burn yeah i mean like every
anybody you could think of
yeah so it just that's the problem with
the fitness industry right it's like
everybody is
constantly putting out nonsense like
these home workouts bro
these [ __ ] like giant buff ass
[ __ ] right
great bodies and women too they're doing
the goofiest [ __ ] i've ever seen
you know it does not work
water bought like clorox well yeah i get
it if you don't have weight i understand
yeah you need a little extra low but
it's like
people think in their head they're like
yeah use this when it's like bro you're
not going to be going home
and doing squats with the [ __ ]
laundry detergent
i don't care how much you like fitness
you're just not going to do it where
people are doing
the towel workouts towel resistance
right like everyone's door handles
[ __ ] broke because everyone's like
doing pull-ups on it
trust me i tried bro my house is [ __ ]
too old for that [ __ ]
but it's crazy dog i saw one chick like
having a pillow and she's kneeing it
and doing ball slams with a pillow and
i'm like bro just [ __ ] taking a while
that sounds fun though she's like ah
she's doing billy blanks typo and [ __ ]
you know what i mean
which is fine if if that's what you need
to get moving but it's like don't act
like
yeah if you're a fitness model like this
is what got you yeah don't act like
you're doing that at home because
let's be real that's not what you're
doing so stop it yeah and i don't expect
these guys
and i don't recommend them to come out
right it's just i know bro
i know i mean people like me that are
deep into it that have done things
that you know that do i've done tests
all that type of [ __ ] it's like we know
but also on the other side i understand
why the [ __ ] would you come out and ruin
all everything that you own right but
that reminds me of two things so i gotta
tell you two stories because
but the other one's about fighting this
one's about this so
when i was younger and i first started
working out i got fat burner pills and i
didn't realize that most of it was
caffeine right
right so i was working out with my
friend luis uh
and we're you know we got i got into
working out you know that's
every day after school or i would
[ __ ] ditch school and [ __ ] and go
work out that was my thing
so i used to take this pre-workout
called no explode
because i took i took jack the original
jack it was
off the [ __ ] channel we talked about
that yeah that was probably the most
insane thing i've ever taken in my life
it was that [ __ ] was hey the original
was good
what was it what was in the original
that was illegal that [ __ ] was fun it
was
it would send me through the roof but it
took it took i when i worked at this
high school there was like
he was a junior he took a he took a
bunch of jack 3d
and then he turned jaundice and they had
a [ __ ] take on the hospital and we
haven't seen him
i gave that [ __ ] to a youtuber called uh
his name is joseph vincent right and i
used to play ball back in the day
and this one this is i had one duncan
and [ __ ]
i had one bottle left just one and it
got taken off it was an old-ass bottle
from like a year ago when i was in col
like a few years back and it was all
crusty and [ __ ] but i'm like yo this is
the original [ __ ] formula oh my gosh
and so we uh i gave him some and this is
the last model left i was like you
should try this [ __ ] this shit's great
i didn't know why they took it off the
shelves at that point yeah but
we started playing ball this we ran like
five games back to back to back to back
and the next day that phil he texted me
said he went to the hospital
because he couldn't walk because his
shin splints were so bad
so he was just [ __ ] going through it
that's so bad
yeah to talk on that so the first time i
ever talked jack before my other story
i just right before i get into working
out with my other friends from my old
job right
it was me my friend diego really heavy
set guy like really really heavy set
and i was out of shape so i go and go to
the it was called high health there's
like a store out there
i'm like yo i'm gonna start working out
uh i heard i read about pre-workout i
wanna maybe try it so i can you know
because after school or whatever like
that
he's like oh he's like do you have one
that you're thinking of i'm like no he's
like hey so
we just got this stuff in and straight
up went to the back
opened up the box right in front of me
right he's like it's a new stuff called
jack 3d is supposed to be real good
i was alright cool me and diego were
splitting it never i
you know i wrestled did all [ __ ] but it
been years since i worked out
we go i take a scoop i ran three miles
and went and played [ __ ] six games of
basketball back to back to back
my lips were so dry i started bleeding
on my lips because they were so chap
so we were addicted to that [ __ ] and
because we were sharing it because we
went half on it
it it went away in like two weeks i
think right actually
or something as i went back to go get it
two weeks later they already took it off
so
i also heard it hurt because of the
[ __ ] the someone in the car
of the marines or something like that
took more scoops than they needed and
they had a [ __ ] heart attack and died
bro
i'm looking at the original label they
don't give any dosage
like they don't they just tell you
what's basically in it which is like
what you'd find in normal pre-workout
yeah this is the original but they don't
put any of the dosage
i took a quarter scoop and uh joseph
that day i think he took a full scoop
i took a full scoop and i was [ __ ]
nuts with that so i used to do circuit
training and then after circuit training
i would play ball for like three or four
games and i would
i wasn't fine but then i needed that
[ __ ] it would make you go through the
[ __ ] room bro
these instructions like the dosage
instructions are so complicated
that means you probably shouldn't take
it dude i was i've never read any of
that i was genuinely when the guy told
me that it got taken out i was like
physically mad yeah i wanted to punch
something
like there was something in that [ __ ]
that was something addictive bro i was
dude but
hey bro that got me started at least
because i was like dude i gotta come not
a single pre-workout has ever come close
to that ever the holy grail
there's some good ones but never so to
go back to that story right i had no
explode
and then we got these free samples of
eno explode 2.0
right so my thing is i used to take two
scoops
of eno explode in my in my thing because
i was one serving was two scoops
so i only had one full scoop left and i
had this eno explode [ __ ] packet
then it'll explode 2.0 packet so i was
like oh i'll take this scoop and i'll
take the no
2.0 and it'll be like one serving yeah
my diamonds didn't realize it was one
whole serving in that packet
see that's that's the [ __ ] up part
about it so i take the whole packet and
i take one scoop
and my friend has fat burner pills right
so i'm like all right cool and i hadn't
eaten and we just had gotten off school
i was like all right cool i'll take
these too right literally i was fine at
the gym and he'll he can [ __ ] bow
down and
go by this story we're sitting at the
gym all of a sudden
i got so emotional i started crying i
felt so
weird i was like what the [ __ ] bro why
am i crying right now bro
and i just i couldn't [ __ ] function i
felt like
i got hit with like a tidal wave of
something i was like dude what the [ __ ]
is wrong with me right
we so we go back to his house i'm
sitting there crying i'm like dude what
the [ __ ] is wrong with me right now dude
dude my dick didn't work for a whole
[ __ ] week i was so scared bro
i took so much caffeine in one surfing
bro
i think the pills had 300 milligrams
that's it took those that one scoop of
no explode and a whole [ __ ] serving
of 2.0
jesus christ so that might be a thousand
milligrams okay well
i was sick i couldn't eat like for
almost three days i didn't even want to
eat
dog you went through the same symptoms
of somebody who got their heart broken
i know you started crying addicted to it
yeah yeah i know bro dude it was you
could have the big red one
trust me i know that [ __ ] too like no
but
dude i for real like i was sitting like
what the [ __ ] bro
i couldn't control my emotions i was i
think i was just so amped up on caffeine
my body didn't know
what the [ __ ] today that's [ __ ] crazy
and so dude yeah my dick didn't work for
a whole week
and i was like bro i was getting really
nervous and then so i didn't go to the
gym the whole week i took
nothing and eventually like my body got
back to normal but
that that reminds me of those [ __ ]
fat burner pills yeah because those have
so much [ __ ] that's what it mostly is
if you don't look at it so
in my head i'm like [ __ ] i'll just take
these pills whatever [ __ ] it
on top of already the excessive amount
of caffeine i already took i remember a
hydroxy cut it was so big when it came
out yeah i remember that actually it
would just make me sweat because it
might be so hot and i'm like what the
[ __ ] is because the caffeine was so
[ __ ] high you're just like
[ __ ] you're like sweating and [ __ ] i
hate that feeling too when hydroxyl
when you get too much caffeine
hydroxycodone was [ __ ] hydroxycut and
just standing in place
yeah and they're all like they're
[ __ ] bodybuilders those fools are
like
two percent body fat yeah shooting that
commercial on like like i got like this
in four weeks you're like uh-huh [ __ ]
that
i didn't know this but then you know
people were telling me um not people
there was a guy who
who was a model for another fat burning
pill and he got paid to
to um just bloat so they he would bloat
for four weeks
and then from that he was that was his
before yeah and then they would make him
do the hydroxyl give you a meal plan
they give you a workout
they give you everything that you need
yeah and then just say at the end of it
they use a supplement yeah that's it
they bloated him up like a [ __ ]
dog you know i realize this too people
can buy
fake before and after pictures of like
random people on the internet that
they'd never trained
and put them on their website you could
buy fake testimonials from people off
fiverr
and i was like yo this is like fake
video testimonials
and you just tell them what you want to
say and it's it's just like the more i
was looking at this i was like yo this
[ __ ] is so toxic
that's just like being awesome that's
also why there's so much money in the
fitness
there is there really is so much money
and it's like if you're if you're not
willing to [ __ ] kind of sell your
soul there's a lot of guys that do it
really really well
but most of them are just feeding you
like crushed
[ __ ] it's all crocs and [ __ ] that's why
it's hard to i feel like for people who
have um
very honest and straightforward uh
fitness programs that they give them
they
sometimes people have this really
unrealistic expectation of what they
want to get in a very short amount
it's also because of these [ __ ] guys
that are like doing steroids and then
they don't tell people that they're
they're all natural it's like okay
you look at these natural bodybuilders
this is not across the board this is
some of them right
at some point in their life they were
probably on steroids they just didn't
tell you that oh they're off now
especially back in the day all natural
you know what i mean but it's like in
the day supplements they didn't know
what the [ __ ] they were taking bro
i've heard some stories about some of
the guys that i've trained with a lot of
older people
they look back at the [ __ ] they were
taking and how they were feeling how
their body changes
they were most likely taking some
[ __ ] steroids and they just didn't
[ __ ] know about it dude yep because
even arnold was talking i forgot what i
was uh listening to but arnold was
basically saying like
he was talking about his steroid usage
but he goes nowadays when people use
steroids i
they don't know how much they're doing
they don't know how much they're putting
in their body they're going very very
excessive with it
what's bodybuilding now he goes it's
just all about size he goes bodybuilding
used to be an art
it was about symmetry yeah you know not
overgrowing too much muscle not being
too big here not being too small here
he goes now it's just about being a
monster so what happened to this sport
so that's true bro that [ __ ] looks so
uncomfortable to me too yeah like being
that big i think phil heath won like
year after year
[ __ ] can't tie their shoes he's
so like he's so big
nine times mr olympia yeah but it's like
like i just i look at it like how are
you comfortable you see how distended
his belly is though yeah
yeah like when he's not when he's
relaxed
comes all the way out here what is that
why is your belly so big from from all
that
some of the drugs like hgh i think it is
like that you it's like one of the side
effects is you get
at the start of the big ass [ __ ]
stomach yeah but they say that it grows
your uh
organs the way it grows i don't even
know yeah i think
what is human growth hormone for like
why the [ __ ] how can people just get
that [ __ ]
but how do you just get it like you just
go into like a gnc and like can i get
some human growth yeah you gotta i think
you gotta know somebody for that you
gotta know so comment below
for uh all the hgh david wants to get on
tess and hch so go ahead and seriously
guys how do i get something yeah
i'm like yo what's david right he's
gonna be [ __ ] stupid actually you
know i actually just talked to um
nadine did like this whole thing uh on
barbell where he was talking about when
he used to use steroids
i think nadeem says is he off now yeah
he's not using anymore that's good i
think nadeem said that uh human growth
hormone i have to fact check my [ __ ] was
originally used for people who are of
cancer patients
yeah i thought that was like okay that
makes sense
test builds uh i think it's red or white
blood cells whatever the good ones are
that help fight viruses it helps build
that [ __ ] same with like sarms and stuff
like that but
that's why i like nadine because like if
i meet someone new
and i start they start asking me about
like my numbers or something like that
and then sometimes i just tell i was
like yeah but you know i was on [ __ ]
i was like i was on [ __ ] to get those
but i mean it was like it was cool
people asked me i'm always straight up i
just i can't stand the lying
but what you were saying before is like
they all these expectations about
coaching and stuff sometimes it makes
coaching hard yeah because
like i've tapped into me so many times
where i get people and their program
looks so plain to them right
yeah but it's like i'm trying to build
your foundation first because i
see you lift right i've been doing it
for a little bit right so i kind of know
i got to a certain level i was you know
international elite whatever like that
right
so i can kind of see how people are but
they see people doing all this crazy ass
[ __ ] [ __ ] and stuff like that it's
like
you can't just go into that they think
oh they're doing that and they're
getting so strong so i just need to go
[ __ ] do that
but that's the whole thing it's like
people are on [ __ ] steroids and
you're always
working out very difficult for people
who just haven't done it before either
because they feel like they don't know
where to start so they go
well after i do this what's my next
movement that i have to do it's like
well you didn't even [ __ ] finish this
one first yeah
you know you don't even know that's like
when you like when you talk with like
for me when i talk with clients it's
like you have to talk to them with
concepts and fundamentals and like
principles you can't just tell them like
all right do x y and z because
a lot of the times if you don't if you
don't teach them how to do
it they won't be self-sustainable and
they won't ever like figure out how to
like work out for themselves in the long
term
yeah right because people will work with
work with uh trainers or whatever for a
short period of time
but what happens when they stop working
out with them they're like oh well [ __ ]
it i don't know and then
they start gaining some weight they stop
working out they stop being active and
it's a whole
thing of uh just them not staying on top
of it because they don't want to learn
how to train or they're not being taught
properly how to train
yeah because from what people tell you
as far as like bodybuilders
it really depends it's so much nonsense
out there depending on who you get your
facts from
on how you how to train and what
exercises are good yada yada yada
a lot of it is fluff and a lot also what
gets you results is the boring [ __ ]
no matter what the fundamentals across
the board with sports anything
will get you farther than all the fancy
nonsense you know it's like fighting
yeah exactly the basics you're gonna
learn you're gonna do superman punches
before you start learning how to throw a
jab
no doing basics and then this one i work
out so simple
i do my basic movements like my squat
bench deadlift and then i have my little
accessories yep
for it but you know sometimes i see
people doing like all this
crazy ass [ __ ] i'm just like all right
nonsense there's time and places for it
like bands and chains and [ __ ]
like i like that i've done it before but
kids first
first meet first program ever they want
to oh i want to do chains and bands and
[ __ ] i'm like
let's make sure we you can lift yeah
yeah first protecting [ __ ] it's gonna be
[ __ ] with bands and chains on yeah and
then you you just have those dumb
coaches you have
this is my perfect segue right you have
like all those fake coaches like joshua
fabia
i'm calling you out school there's hey
the reason why i did that because the
other story i wanted to tell you is this
so
joshua fabian dude that guy bro that
[ __ ] so after the first fight right
and he was
he was making it all about himself right
he was in the headline
part bro he wanted all the headlines and
[ __ ] oh yeah i've been watching ufc for
a long time i did watch ultimate fighter
1 and [ __ ] i know who diego is right
i like diego i got this [ __ ] on dvd yeah
for like i like diego bro so
when he he diego posted something on his
instagram
i commented on it i think i'm like bro i
[ __ ] love diego
i just feel like this is such a bad
situation for him
i think i commented that on that right
and then so like
maybe just three weeks ago i went to go
out try and look for diego's instagram i
couldn't find it
what the [ __ ] and then i was on our we
out here one yeah and like
i searched diego and it worked that full
blocked me yeah i blocked you diego
blocked me on instagram why
i guess because i commented that i guess
i don't [ __ ] know this whole time i'm
like damn diego deleted his uh
instagram and then literally just right
before this fight
you get a notification on our other
instagram page so i'm looking at it
when are we out here yeah and i go so i
search diego on we out here
and he's there like the whole i'm like
this [ __ ] blocked me
bro i was like i bet joshua was like
give me the give me your phone diego
give me your phone and he'd do this i'm
sure he went through all the comments
that weren't
positive right about him and all that
type of [ __ ] they probably got so
[ __ ] mad or something like that it's
so
it's so weird just watching the
trajectory that he's gone into it's just
i just don't want him to fight anymore
nah bro he's got he doesn't need if
he if he if he decides to fight he's got
to drop that fool
because this full josh fabian or
whatever the all he does
is go on ever like he was on arrow
helwani's and he's arguing with aaron
hewani talking about how he doesn't get
credit
and it's like bro it's if you're a coach
if you're truly
the interest if you truly have the
interest of your fighter and your
athlete
you're not on interviews or instagram
talking about like i deserve my credit
you think trevor whitman is talking
exactly about how like
what a great coach he is no he's he's he
cares about justin gaichi all he cares
about is he gets his shine
he gets all the accolades for his
performance and that's when the fighter
does well that's when you get your shine
that's
that's it and you don't gotta say [ __ ]
bro cause you're not the one fighting
you're not the one that that
that took the low blow from michael
pereira yeah
look at henry's coach the [ __ ] uh
what's called mexican elton john
yeah like him there he is he is bro he
is like he started getting uh
highlighted when henry cejudo became the
double champ and then when uh
when what's it called patricio pitbull
yeah people the people
yeah he [ __ ] won his championship so
he was two double champs bro yeah
exactly and it's like bro
this guy is doing it all [ __ ] wrong
he's
he's literally a crazy person he the
holy and complex to the max
because he's he four foot eleven my guy
he found the only fighter he could do
this with though yeah
yeah i'm really curious to see how he
did it like i really because it's
you know it's obviously gross as [ __ ]
that he did that but it's also kind of
fascinating that he did that i'm kind of
weirded out when i see
i went on his page a while back right
and i see students there and these
people i'm like
how do you not do any of your research
before you sign up for this class and
you're giving this person money it's
buying because there's so much people
that are
are easily brainwashed and it's it's
weird because like i always use
examples like you see they make movies
and they have people like this right
they just buy into whatever
but i mean they get those ideas for
these characters from real [ __ ] life
yeah so there's people
like that and that's all it is it's just
people that just buy into this [ __ ]
stupid-ass hype
he knows how to talk and he probably
finds a certain people that know how to
that buy into his [ __ ] talk he
reminds me of uh steven seagal
that's what it is like the way he does
his demonstrations yeah
this guy this guy could run a cult bro
like he's he's that kind of guy
and i just feel bad and it sucks because
like if someone were to sit down with
diego and really try to explain this to
him he's kind of so
brainwashed into this guy's
words that he will never see it well
he's sitting here in the fight and he's
starting to doing this [ __ ] where he
extends his hands out like this
i'm like what the [ __ ] are you doing
you're gonna get crap and lo and behold
he gets cracked
every time he does that yep so i'm
figuring out what the [ __ ] is going on
and at the same time it's like with
joshua fabia whatever his [ __ ] name
is
if he's coaching diego whoever
like the the person that's getting the
most negative effect is diego sanchez
like because josh ain't in the ring
fighting people bro yeah
this there's a video of this dude
chasing all these fighters around with a
[ __ ] knife
in the ufc like like and it's like bro
what
the [ __ ] is going on and other fighters
that were there were like all right this
is some nutty ass [ __ ]
yeah because there's but then he'll say
like oh see these guys trained with me
they they see they see the the awareness
but he's such a charlatan
it's like it's it's what was it crazy
that this is even
like there's nothing the ufc or anybody
else could do about it because it's it's
diego's choice it's
who he's he's training with but it's
just like [ __ ] it's almost so
upsetting and criminal to see that this
dude is getting massively taken
advantage of like this
yeah and you know when he brought a
[ __ ] stephen bonner in
i was like all right cool yeah hopefully
that's that's definitely as good
and then he's saying like oh i was
training with stefan and [ __ ] like all
right cool
but it kind of seems like stefan's kind
of going towards the way that diego is
yeah but then again too it might be him
just like dog i mean
what the [ __ ] am i gonna do i can't also
he also could be
really good friends with diego and sees
what's happening to diego
and like you know what maybe i should
just go along with this but sit here and
really try to help my friend
i read this like really interesting
story about how stefan bonner and diego
started training with each other it was
like recent
and it was we're doing research for like
we out here and the story was
is that they kind of came together
because they were talking about like
ufos and they had like a similar
sighting or some [ __ ] like that
and him and diego like kind of were like
linked up or like yo let's start
training yada yada the rest is history
and it was because of they were talking
about like ufos and all that stuff
whatever
stephen bond has always been a little
weird he's lost especially when he's on
his own
he's you know he's had his issues dude
he has duis he has all this crazy
remember when he fought anderson oh and
he got [ __ ] up that was one of the
craziest fights he's got
[ __ ] he got in the stomach and literally
lifted up in the air like a [ __ ]
anime or something
but stefan bonner was talking mad [ __ ]
too before that was he remember how tan
and jack he was
yeah he was talking some mad [ __ ] i'm
like yeah i mean
at least he's training with steph and
bonner though you know at least he's
training at the gym
there's bodies there based off his last
performance this is probably
the worst diego sanchez he's gotten
exponentially worse than his last fight
he
yeah he looked he looked like someone
that doesn't fight
until he got on the ground right he got
on the ground he was doing he was trying
to throw up some submissions i'm like
okay
i was getting i texted you guys i was so
mad at jake matthews because yeah
that was a fight so out of this misery
bro just knock him out
just knock dude when he goes down to the
floor with him i was literally screaming
at my friend patrick i'm like bro
body kicks were there all day didn't
throw [ __ ] one
i didn't see the fight i just saw the
flying knee attempt didn't throw
one kick bro yeah i'm like dude why
aren't you throwing any kicks he's not
blocking the jorge basketball
he did the hands behind his back bro and
then he runs up with the [ __ ] he's
finding he gets
cracked was still in the middle of the
ring and he still
didn't reach him at all he wasn't even
close yeah
but like watching that is like okay it's
funny but it also makes me feel so
sad for him yeah bro because he's he
wants to fight again
and it's just like he doesn't look like
he's physically in good shape because
who knows what the [ __ ] joshua fave like
i would love to be a fly on the wall
doug
just seeing the training sessions let's
just see what it's about like what are
you trying to accomplish
that's sarah just roasted his ass bro
the fact that she said
matt sarah bro yeah bro he's a [ __ ]
true g the fact that this [ __ ] guy
has the audacity
to go up to a couple of guys then thomas
and [ __ ] mad sarah i think dana was
there too right no dana wasn't it was
just dean thomas
the fact that you go up to these [ __ ]
mma legends pioneers in the sport as
they're eating breakfast as they're
eating breakfast
to go up to him and start beef with a
guy that
doesn't like you for a very good reason
that could [ __ ] you up
yeah in an instant and it's just like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about bro
that serious response
is so funny because you just said like
who are you yeah
he's like the school of whatever and
he's like wow that's that's that's
not cool you see you see how he's like
you wanna know why because i don't give
a [ __ ]
bro cause i'm sitting here trying to
have breakfast with my [ __ ] friends
what is your name i think the funny
thing was he just started mouthing off
and matt sarah couldn't even recollect
who he was who knows who you are
he's like well i think you're training
it's silly he's like but who cares
you're not my guy you're not training my
guys i'm not training you guys bro so
[ __ ] off
yeah bro and that's my school of
self-awareness school of self-awareness
he has 5 000 followers on instagram half
of those are probably from
people you want to see them yeah people
just want to see this [ __ ] that he's
doing bro
it's so crazy it's it's literally like
the mcdojo
the you know it's one of those shits bro
and just like
i feel bad and like i was saying what
nick was saying like that flying nisha
it's funny but also you feel
bad because i think what i heard was
that
what made him do it was like joshua was
telling remember all those sprints we
ran for training
remember all those sprints we ran for
training let's see it or some [ __ ] like
that and then
what spurs that fool was fat as [ __ ]
that's what led into the flying knee
and the thing is too it's like look if
you are so it looks like he does like
body work and like healing or whatever
that's fine whatever
if you that's what you want to do that's
cool but you shouldn't be
trying to take over some ufc's
fight camp bro like what are you talking
about you could literally put anybody
else in that position
that you know might watch ufc or
whatever mma might be an enthusiast
and i guarantee you they'll probably
watch the training session and go you
know what
this is not okay i mean i want to they
should do a criminal
ufc series where coaches fight each
other that'd be dope dude
the hobby would just murder a bunch of
people he's so good bro that fool is so
good have you seen
trevor women hey trevor whitman got
hands bro he's
nice well trevor i don't i think the
only reason why i haven't looked it up
is because trevor whitman says he has
like physical issues while he can
you see all the belts he got bro his
boxing bro
he's
i mean he fought that's right yeah so
he's like go
go do it bro there's so many good great
coach fighters you know what i mean like
it's
i honestly think that you do have to
fight to
not completely but you have to know what
a fighter is going through yeah you know
i mean so you've had to done it at least
a little bit
you know that full probably never spars
he's probably never done any of that
bro he's literally like just watching
him move you're like oh this guy
has no idea what the [ __ ] he's talking
about like just watching him watching
him demonstrate things you're like
everyone smells [ __ ] on that he's
such an odd human being i wonder how he
even got to meet diego in the first
place
like how did that happen they were he
had said like they met somewhere at some
gym
that they were working out at and diego
said that
they did some wrestling and josh pulled
off
some wrestling moves on diego that
surprised diego because diego is
you know like almost six foot or
whatever like i don't know how [ __ ]
tall he is
and josh is five two he's like a guy
this small
should not be able to pull off these
moves that he did on me he's like so i
was like hmm
maybe this guy does know what he's
talking about he's like and then it's
history
i'm like bro you left who cares he was
like oh i wasn't getting the one-on-one
time from jackson week
of course not do you have an active
fighter in jon jones
you have an active fighter and [ __ ]
holly holm who yeah she doesn't have
like the best record right now but she's
still a huge [ __ ] fighter
of course they're focusing more on them
why wouldn't they
right and so but at least you're at the
gym you're training with those bodies
so you really think leaving jackson wink
is gonna
this for this is gonna be better for you
well it was watching him hold knits dog
this is abysmal
right it's just
it's here's the thing it's like
yeah if you're not good at holding mints
that's one thing but it's like the
context of what you're doing
yeah he's doing non he's doing literal
nonsense
yeah he's a crazy person that's like oh
yeah this might work
yeah he's showing him an arm drag into a
face lap
like for what for what you're going to
knock somebody out with that no
people are such good scam artists yeah
is people are so good at scamming people
like i i almost want to just have a
conversation with them or maybe see the
people
they're probably good at selecting the
right human of course
he's being a predator kind of yeah i
mean like that's what it is because
there's no way somebody like that would
come up to me
and said let me see your arm he goes can
you go see that i'm like get the [ __ ]
out of my face dude
or i'll punch him in the [ __ ] head
don't [ __ ] talk to me it's like
remember those [ __ ] wristbands that
they sold
oh the balance of your balance bro i was
literally gonna bring that up when we
talked about the live stream yeah
and it's it's such placebo effect let me
tell you the [ __ ] so
i was at the mall and this is glendale
this is not too long ago yeah so they
had the
it's like a certain type of only sell
them at malls yeah of course it's only
at malls and it's always like a 16 year
old girl
yeah at a kiosk so she comes up to me
and she goes sir have you heard of these
things
i'm like wow it helps with your
equilibrium and your balance right and
she goes bring out your arm
right and she goes i'm gonna pull it
down and you're not gonna have the
bracelet on right and she goes
she tries to pull it down she goes wow
you're really strong
she's hanging on your [ __ ] shoes oh
you're really strong i'm like i'm
actually not
and she goes okay but you see you kind
of moved a little bit right she goes
okay well i'm gonna put the wristband on
you and then now watch
right and i do it but right when she
does it i throw my arm down i'm like
whoa
she goes oh that's not supposed to
happen bracelet that makes me weaker
i'll take three
please you're really strong well
normally what happens is that
you know when you did the first time i
shouldn't have been able to you know i
should be able to bring your arm down
and make you not balanced
i'm like do you really believe in this
stuff right i'm looking at
burial's just kind of like trying to
take you she's like please cuz i'm on
one that day right i was like do you
really believe the stuff she goes
no
she goes no not really this is just a
good summer job and they pay pretty well
and she starts crying david's i [ __ ]
my man i was trying to be i bought two
off of her wow
you're a [ __ ] good guy so the guy the
guy that the that that own the gym that
i work out right
it was cool though it was like silver
and it had like a rainbow rainbow thing
on it
the bracelet was so when i was younger
bro they came out to visit us in arizona
right we went to the mall and chris is
not into all that [ __ ] right and
he's been in fitness for a long time
he goes we're at the mall and they do
the bracelet [ __ ] and we're sitting
there watching and then this is right
when it first came out so
there's [ __ ] a crowd watching this
[ __ ] right so chris is like
let me go see this [ __ ] he's like does
it right and chris is a big dude
she can't [ __ ] move him all right
when she puts it in
puts it on tries to do it again can't
[ __ ] move him and he
goes like yeah this stuff's fake like i
can't believe like
everybody's actually watching this this
is all fake yeah this is
all placebo and then we just laughed
bro but it really is placebo dude 100
because they're making you
they're already planning it in your mind
and making you do something but in my
head before i walked up there i'm like
i'm not gonna let you do this so like
the worst one out of all the placebos is
like pretending to give someone like
drugs or something like that yeah
and then watching them fake trip yeah we
did that one time growing up where
they gave like fake weed to this one
girl and just watching her pretend like
she was high i was like man
i don't know what that's right i'm so
embarrassed you're funnier than that
the power of the mind bro it's very
strong when you give somebody weed and
they keep saying it's not working but
they're acting high as [ __ ]
it's the funniest [ __ ] [ __ ] we're like
hey bro you give me though i was like
dog
this [ __ ] y'all need to give me some
[ __ ] serious [ __ ] and then he's
saying he's talking to the wall
i'm right here bro he's like man i don't
feel none of this [ __ ] because that's
not like out though he's like this ain't
me good
it was like falling asleep
[Laughter]
that's so somebody give somebody some
fake weedy [ __ ] he's [ __ ] hilarious
oregano
yeah dude it was at the same house too
bro dude i had so many stories so the
did i ever tell you my hit and run story
no bro should you tell this
yeah because this is ten years go ahead
yeah dude no for real as long as time i
go we're at someone's house watching ufc
fights right and it was me and one of my
old friends who i'm not gonna say his
name because [ __ ] him
and so we were in the same car right and
so as we're leaving the house right
the we had tp'd one of our other friends
cars because it was his birthday right
so there's toilet paper
all around it and [ __ ] like that um
what's it called [ __ ] toilet paper
all around we're leaving
he sees it so he they start grabbing all
of it and they start throwing it in my
car
so we're just doing a back and forth
[ __ ] throwing into each other's car
right
but the second time i came around i
started my car because it was automatic
so we throw it in there i throw it in
there deep like in his back seat so he
has to go in
i was like getting get and get in so i
put my [ __ ] in reverse and step on the
gas
and you just and then we're going back
and all of a sudden
boom [ __ ] flying like this and i just
look at my homie i'm like
he's like bro go go go go god dude what
the [ __ ] did i hit
we hit the [ __ ] we hit a van right we
hit some [ __ ] van that was outside
i'm like oh [ __ ] it's a go alex [ __ ]
go so i just [ __ ] zoom off and [ __ ]
i text them because i always used to
take this full to school right i was
like hey
we're leaving extra early i gotta drive
by this house make sure we didn't
[ __ ] this [ __ ] van up right so we go
and there was just like a little black
mark on it bro but
that [ __ ] was funny but the the reason
why i remember that story because one of
the people that was involved i'm not
gonna say names because i know some of
my people from arizona do watch these
when i'm on there
it was one of those people to that same
group that did the fake weed [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] hilarious man that [ __ ]
was [ __ ] funny
this has nothing to do with that but i
remember there was this girl in high
school
shout out very sweet girl her name is
luna so luna
sweet girl i believe it was like
it's not funny but it's funny it was a
month before
prom so she uh
she broke both of her already the fact
legs you were laughing before you said
that before
i went out laughing oh my god it's funny
to me because she broke both of the legs
before i dance
i have to go pee i'm gonna leave and i'm
gonna come right back
i guess like in the middle of the night
her boyfriend was supposed to
re-park the car right so she was like
trying to tell him like
how far she was supposed to be from the
car and i might be making this part up
but somehow she ended up behind the car
and between the other car
oh my boyfriend bro i don't know why but
he
gassed it on the reverse mug and then he
crushed her legs in between cards and
she broke
both of her [ __ ] legs before prop
duck oh that oh i thought you meant
already when they were broken he did
that oh okay that's how he broke him
that's how she broke her legs
her legs got sandwiched and we reversed
the card
that's just [ __ ] crazy i think they
broke up too too i would too be like
what the [ __ ]
did you go to prom though yeah you did
go to prom but i just remember she had
to be like on like these metal crutches
and [ __ ] her legs were all bionic
that [ __ ] was nuts man i'm like yo she
broke both of her
[ __ ] legs bro that sucks i mean how
bad that [ __ ] hurt bro
i don't know but that poor sweet girl
though that [ __ ] was nuts
i just i couldn't wrap my head around
what happened they said
she broke both of her legs i'm like how
her boyfriend
reversed his car and smashed i was like
on purpose or
she was nuts that shit's crazy bro and
seeing people get hit with a car
oh if you've seen it like have you ever
seen that in person i saw
well i never saw an action okay i
actually hit somebody with the car once
i'm sorry he didn't want to say that
they need that but it was super [ __ ]
slow it was when i first got this isuzu
trooper it was like this a 4x4 suv
and uh i picked up my girlfriend and i
wasn't paying attention
and it was like this 70 year old dude
and i was just kind of creeping real
slow because i just had it off the break
but because i was just looking at her
talking to the and the car was creeping
before in the front of a vons or
it was a safe way for us and all of a
sudden i hear doom old man is on top of
the car
with this cake going hey what the [ __ ]
oh
[ __ ] and i hit the break but he didn't
get hit hard he didn't fall over
anything but he was on top of the car
because i think he just got
freaked out he grabbed yeah grabbed my
hood but i saw that happen
yeah bro no the uh nick [ __ ] got
himself locked out little [ __ ]
all right start rapping while i'm gone
all right hey what's up genius brain
are we out here oh [ __ ] all right
no but so cheating on that when i was in
high school so
to pay to park in the [ __ ] parking
lot
was about 400 [ __ ] dollars well you
gotta pay for that at my school you had
a
you had to buy a parking pass you gotta
buy a parking pass
it was so [ __ ] expensive we didn't
have money like that so obviously we
didn't pay for parking pass we just
parked down the street that was by the
school had all-day parking i mean it
wasn't like yeah
two hours or whatever so i used to park
there all the time
until like senior year when i was like
straight up [ __ ] like actual homies
with the outside security guard he used
to give me a spot
but one day i'm like walking and i'm
behind this girl and it's about from
like
right here where i'm at to maybe if you
open this door the next wall right
so that about that far i'm sitting there
walking to school
and then you get to a spot where there's
a stop sign and you cross the crosswalk
and you walk to the rest of the school
i'm saying that i'm walking i'm looking
down i just i just happen to start
looking up looking up
and i s and we're getting close to the
stop sign this girl's at the stop sign
she starts walking by
this [ __ ] girl just gets taken out
right in front of me bro
she goes flying her books go flying and
she lands
she lands like on the [ __ ] concrete
oh my god did she survive yeah i was
like
what the [ __ ] so i sprint over there
right she had
her ankle was broken she's like bleeding
all over her legs and [ __ ] like that
i was like what the [ __ ] the car dipped
out oh there's people
people like she's okay though yeah she
she survived she survived
but they people started running after
her like people just outside
people in cars saw it they started
chasing after this after this person
crazy but to watch like this person she
got
lifted up in the air because so what it
was is
that the person that here was actually a
student at the school as well
right so what the story was is he wasn't
paying attention at the stop sign
because there's a four-way stop sign
just ran straight through it and [ __ ]
hit her right so that kid that kid
started getting death threats from this
girl's family and she he never showed
back up to school again
obviously right he had to pay for you
her medical
stop signs you know yeah but to to watch
it and just hear that [ __ ]
about it you just brought up two [ __ ]
memories like of mine
like right now so two things that you
guys seen a lot of people get hit by
cars so well
there's a buddy of mine scott heaps of
old ass man
bro you missed that story i i didn't hit
a cyclist but it's like let's crash into
my car
through my windshield in the miata
through the windshield through the
windshield he like came through sitting
next to you like what we're doing right
now he's like what's
up he was halfway through he's like you
okay he's half through my he's like
halfway through my windshield
this is my card yeah bro there was a
so one time well he was alluding to i
didn't hit this old guy hella hard i
just i
was just kind of dragged
70 year old dude is this a story i
missed this is this
well the first story that you missed was
the girl luna who broke both of her legs
basically i'm just saying it again
[ __ ] long story short
it was like a month before prom i don't
know exactly what happened but she ended
up being behind his car while he was
re-parking
and i think she was trying to get him to
get close to the to whatever the parking
situation he wasn't paying attention
and he just gasped his car reversed and
smashed her legs
in between two between two cars and
broke both of them
like what happened in the office
remember when amy yeah
crashed into dwight with a prius yeah
but this dude busted both of her legs
before prom and then she had bionic legs
she had those phone calls
i feel bad i take that back i take that
back i feel bad hey luna's
she punches the principal in the face
like [ __ ] you
austin 316.
out in the middle of it stutters the
[ __ ] prom queen
she had two white claws oh god this is
too [ __ ] funny
i want to hear these stories though yeah
yeah shout out to okay so
shout out to luna there's this one dude
from high school that if even until we
beat now i didn't realize how sensitive
it was about the story
because to us is [ __ ] hilarious so
i'm not gonna say his name because i
know he's very sensitive
i can't wait to hear what happens bro
this is
reminding me all these memories are
flooding back so
this this [ __ ] makes me and my buddy
corey
gonna choke on his [ __ ]
this [ __ ] made me die [ __ ] laughing
because
me and my buddy corey so we would walk
back home together right because i
didn't live that far from my high school
but somebody was on their cell phone
this is before the the law came in that
you couldn't talk
on your cell phone as you're driving so
there's a stop sign here and the guy's
supposed to hit a left on the road
so my buddy oh about the same let's call
him peter so my buddy peter right
peter said he didn't see him and he just
hits a hard right just zooms and he hits
peter
peter goes on to doug i cried laughing
in front of him because it was so
funny how he got hit he got hit hard he
flew on top of the hood rolled onto the
top of the car
and when he was on top right you thought
he was just going to stop
slightly he just starts rolling slowly
off all the way to the pad
comes off of the truck the slowest roll
off the trunk
and the guy comes out he goes are you
okay and you would think he would be
like no i need to get your information
and this dude starts crying he just goes
just get the [ __ ] out of here man
was he white was it white dude no it was
an asian dude that got hit but uh the
guy that hit him was an asian dude too
uh
so a few years back we were just
chopping it up right i was like hey bro
remember you got [ __ ] hit by that car
and i'm dying
laughing right i'm crying and this was
just like i don't think that's funny
but if like you're good afterwards you
kind of like you can't get better
he was fine but but that's that's what
they say it's like if you get hit by a
car you're supposed to go on top of the
hood so you could roll off it
and then well that's exactly what
happened he was on top that's what the
step guys do that's what yoshi
does yeah he was on top and then it
stopped and they went
this rolled off right there yeah but you
know
when you brakes follow them when you're
talking about the guy through the
windshield right so this there's this
park
next to my house called uh that i used
to live in called countryside park right
that park's a little ghetto but there
was a dude in my high school
that used to drive like a [ __ ] maniac
right and i was actually walking home
from my buddy esteban's house
at countries and he lives really right
next to countryside park
i [ __ ] [ __ ] you not i cannot make
this up there are people who witness
this [ __ ]
i don't know what happened that caused
him to veer off the road but there was a
dude in my high school and he had this
busted ass blue
this dark blue nissan nissan sentra you
know that square [ __ ] yeah
so back in the day the the those
windshields
actually shatter they don't spider web
so if you go through it you just fly
right through
so there was a hawaiian kid that went to
our school big ass [ __ ] right
i [ __ ] you [ __ ] not i told this story
on jk news like 10 years ago
but this dude big as [ __ ] he wasn't
wearing his seatbelt how much do you
think he weighs
probably like 230 easy [ __ ] he was in
our football team
okay so full i don't know what happened
but i remember he hit one of the
sprinkles and like the sprinklers went
all crazy but when he hit the break
[ __ ] um this hawaiian cat i'm not
gonna say his name
flew through the [ __ ] windshield
flying hawaii and
i'm not even lying he flew through the
windshield we saw him tumble
he goes gets up lands on both of his
feet and he goes
[ __ ] are you okay he starts running
towards the car to check out his obi
dude oh my god
he flew out the [ __ ] front window
rolled tumbled landed on his feet and
was like
oh [ __ ] and he goes to check up on the
other home you see if he's all right hey
[ __ ] are built different y'all
the hawaiian people are
built [ __ ] no different different for
real that's [ __ ] crazy that's [ __ ]
insane yeah that [ __ ] is cannonballed
out of them
like like [ __ ] terminator my guy well
he got lucky because he landed on the
grass area so like countryside park has
a huge grass front so when he hit it he
just chucked and he started rolling on
the grass i'm curious to see if he felt
like really sore the next day i don't
know he because a lot of times like
he didn't come to me yeah he was but he
was he was he was solid after that [ __ ]
i forgot about that story completely
broke when you mentioned about how your
friend got mad
that you brought up the story yeah i
can't i can't believe i forgot this
[ __ ] story so my friend
one of my best friends thomas we call
him teddy right
bro every time i used to bring up the
story afterwards i mean
i don't understand how it's funny i
don't understand how it's so funny i
don't know why everybody's laughing so
much
because so at that same spot that i
parked in school right
there was one day everybody was sitting
on top of my car
and so i wanted to leave and i'm like
yeah i'm like yo
everybody get the [ __ ] off my [ __ ]
car so they finally get off
i start going teddy comes and jumps on
my hood
that's what he gets i have an automatic
car right
so i just take my foot off the [ __ ]
my foot's off to break
but the car steadily starts going faster
because it's automatic right
so we're start going and we start going
fast he's like don't stop
don't stop i'm like bro he's like stop
stop
stop so i [ __ ] hit the brake right we
fly forward this fool goes
flying and right when i hit the brake i
let go of the brake he goes flying and
rolling and my car's still going so the
slam on the brakes again bro
but all i see is his full feet come up
in the air and he's rolling on the
street right
i'm like oh [ __ ] and i thought like
maybe like ran him over again or some
[ __ ]
but bro we were laughing so [ __ ] hard
oh my god he rolled out i got a big ass
cut on his [ __ ] forehead and [ __ ] bro
but everybody just saw him just get
thrown off my [ __ ] car hey
i can't believe i forgot that that's
what you get though bro don't
jump on moving vehicles did i tell you
guys about the story about the
dude that was uh hood surfing the one
like florida
no so there was a so people used to hood
surf in high school right so you just
hop on the hood and your boy would just
drive off and be cool right
but one of the cats he's a filipino dude
and this guy used to wear so those big
ass jinko jeans those super extra baggy
ones
but they came right here yeah him and
the homie
this guy they were it was so
in front of our my high school floor in
high school right next to it is this
huge field
and so when people get picked up from
school people usually go out that way so
this is a little bit after school where
all
the all everybody got picked up or
whatever right but this [ __ ]
decides to hood surf on this other
dude's car but when you're hood surfing
you're not supposed to zigzag
right so yeah this [ __ ] legs are
gonna [ __ ] decide
i remember the [ __ ] clear as [ __ ] day
he was zig-zagging and you could see
this fool's legs like a [ __ ] doll
just start shaking
like all across the hood you guys start
flexing those [ __ ] my guys flies off
boom starts rolling right and so
the most dramatic most back in the day
we used to say this word
[ __ ] way possible yeah don't say it now
and i do not condone it no but it just
comes
up and the guy starts rolling and the
guy gets out the car and he looks and he
goes
bro are you okay and they cr clasp each
other's hands like old [ __ ] hercules
like
by the forearms and they go bro just get
out of here man
before the cops come get out of here
just in the most emotional thing i've
ever seen in my life
and this fool leaves his homie in the
middle of the street and just jets off
before the cops come and i had to go up
and pick that dude fire him carry him
over my arms
and bring off to the side of the road
and this floor flew off of a [ __ ] car
going like 50 miles an hour as they're
talking david
[Music]
he's like bro just go get out of here
please stop
as you should bro i just remember them
laying down doing this
just get out of here bro get out of here
before the cops come like gravity
[ __ ] dawson creek looking [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up dawson creek remember
that [ __ ] show bro
ain't no show you should slap though no
seventh heaven
when i see your happy faces smiling
bad i can't tell you i'm not
exaggerating me and my brothers used to
get home from school
and jack running into our room the dad
to the dad run into our room we had one
of those big tvs that have like the big
back right and they're black
they got this power got that trump dump
yeah oh [ __ ] out of that
press power takes 10 seconds to [ __ ]
even light up yeah
we used to go to [ __ ] channel
whatever the [ __ ] it was on and watch
seventh heaven bro
that [ __ ] was our [ __ ] bruh damn man you
guys must have been poor poor dude
because like
we have cables look at hella younger
than me you got that tv at that time bro
you should have a flat screen by then we
have the same tv
in our room i remember like the big tv
that we had was in the living room
and it was literally like remember when
the tvs were boxes
it was a giant box it was like the
speaker yeah yeah yeah like that's what
we had for years
and my dad loved it but he never wanted
to get rid of did y'all have the tv with
the remote that was like this
[ __ ] big [ __ ] all too young for that
the one that's on the tv though i'm
talking about the remote was like this
dog
and we had a bug it's like it was so
this is actually kind of smaller than
the actual remote
and the remote was on the table you
would pop it off and then you could
it was like this [ __ ] so funny my
aunt used to have that [ __ ] in her
bedroom i remember when she moved out we
had a we had to get rid of that tv
that tv i [ __ ] you not minimum 400
pounds bro
heavy as [ __ ] never lose the remote
though
those two tvs bro they're [ __ ] heavy
i used to when i worked at best buy i
used to sell tvs
that's what's crazy when you look at the
price of these [ __ ] now bro
i remember when best buy our best buy
got the first 70 inch in right
this [ __ ] was 4 500 at the time
this was 2012 2013. when i was uh 14
years old
uh i remember plasma tvs were popping
but only rich people had that [ __ ]
yeah bro and so uh when i was in korea
my parents this is a long story but my
parents know
um my mom worked at a factory
for one of these people who are
considered one of the richest people in
korea and my mom was actually bet she
passed away
rest in peace yokosuka but she uh she
was the wife of the ceo of this major
company so
they have the formula like the original
formula for red bull and so
oh so they they're they're a company
that um
is the number one medical supply company
on on in in south korea
and so they also own a separate company
where they also sell like snacks and
drinks or whatever they're that [ __ ]
big
my mom was the best friend of that the
person who created that company's
white wife so when we were in korea
uh when i was younger my mom they would
take care of me so i would call her
grandma
i actually didn't know she i wasn't
related to her until i was like uh
15. wow so uh while my parents were in
korea
and my mom was there my dad left to the
states so when i was born my dad was
there but then he went to the states for
about a couple years so he could set up
base
so we could fly over well i was actually
living with them
those rich people and my mom because my
mom was
her personal assistant and she also
worked at the factory so when we went
there when i was 14
i remember seeing a plasma tv and it
blew my mind at 14. i was like what the
[ __ ]
this is a tv look how thin it is that tv
was ten thousand dollars bro
plasmas yeah dude tvs no they used to be
so
[ __ ] expensive yeah it was like this
i i mean i was super young but it was a
really big tv but i remember my dad
telling me how much it cost
and it was like 10 grand like uh
converted into american dollars i wonder
how much
you could what kind of tv you could buy
with ten thousand dollars dude
you could probably buy like a hammock no
yeah you would get you would get the
[ __ ] thing that's absolutely five
inches
[ __ ] bro yeah no dude cause like i'm
telling you i remember when we first got
it in we were like we're never gonna
sell this
yeah 4 500 [ __ ] bucks for this tv i
think we sold like three of them and it
was to people for businesses and [ __ ]
now right and like nowadays you can get
a you can get a [ __ ] 65 inch i think
my friend
patrick just got his 65 65-inch tv for
[ __ ] like i think it was like 500
bucks
for real i'm like bro dude yeah he's
like oh bro we can watch the fights i'm
like no last time i was over there his
[ __ ] dog bit me
i ain't never caught it what the [ __ ]
bro so like i used to walk dogs right so
i kind of know how dogs act and [ __ ]
right
so his dog's a rescue and he's super
sweet hot dog is it uh
i think it's like some kind of pit mix
or something like that
it's dog sweet i like his dog but it was
just funny to me because
every time like he's still super
cautious when he's around me right
and like if i start petting him he likes
it it'll come up to me but
i noticed every time i would get up to
the bathroom he would follow me and be
right on me and be like
yeah what are you doing like super
sketch and like kind of like get really
close to me
and in my head i'm sent to him like oh
it feels like he's like a little
aggressive yeah
being aggressive and then of course
patrick drops the most
nah he just he just wants to play
i hate it when people have the most
aggressive dogs and they go nah he's
just happy to see you blood
see and they don't know this dog's so
new right then he's he is a sweet dog
one
but for some reason so finally i he i
just cut my homie patrick's hair so he
went to the bathroom and i'm going in
there
to go see it and i hear the dog
following me but this time i didn't stop
or anything like that i just kept
walking
this [ __ ] bites me my [ __ ]
cap yo
i'm like oh [ __ ] because it just scared
me
yeah it didn't hurt but like he bit me
like he bit me i'm like oh [ __ ]
and then patch like what i'm like dude
he just [ __ ] bit my leg
and but so what it was is like you could
tell because he's super uh
he was like super um he might he must he
might have been like beating or
something like that right
did i spit on you no no no no i just
remembered uh
my buddy's dog bit a chunk off of this
figure i was wondering if i still had
the scar
yeah so then i just told him i was like
i noticed that i think it was because
he's being
you know because he's like all right
patrick's um
like he registered him like you know as
a
emotional support dog yeah so he's like
he's good for that and all that type of
stuff
i think it was that like you know
patrick's his human right so i'm going
in
i'm a new person and i keep going in his
room i think he was being protective
yeah of like their stuff which is
understandable and like i said even like
[ __ ]
biting me it was like a nibble huh yeah
just like trying to like make sure like
hey where the [ __ ] are you going
it was just so scary especially if it's
a pig
so many [ __ ] times by dogs bro what
the [ __ ] why
yeah dude why you always got beef jerky
in your pocket and [ __ ] but you always
got snacks in your pocket but they're
our own dogs so like the
the biggest two stories right was i
remember
we had a dog named nico and he [ __ ]
hated us for some reason as kids
as we got older he was fine but this
[ __ ] was so bipolar
like he would want you to pet him and
then all sudden start
you're like
so this one day i still have the scars
too
i still have the scars one day he's on
the couch and i just sit down by it and
he does the whole little
he goes on his back and like submitting
yeah yeah and he's like wants you to rub
on his [ __ ] right you're ready to fly so
i'm
i'm rubbing it like this i'm rubbing him
like this
and he's on the couch so i go oh nico
and i put my hand on his head i get
boom bit right on my [ __ ] face right
so he bites me in my face i'm like oh
[ __ ] so i we put him outside i remember
too i was young too i put him on my side
he's staring at him i'm like kick in the
window i'm like
[ __ ] you dude i didn't even go i went
into the [ __ ] bathroom bro i had
three big i have if i shave my face you
can see him i still have him there's
three scars right under my cheek where
he [ __ ] bit me right in my face dude
i was like [ __ ] bro bro as we got older
he got
and he got older obviously too yeah calm
down a lot more the second time this was
actually
it was a lot smaller talk about how to
suck that dog i'm sorry
even if you guys don't stock them up it
was a lot smaller of a mark but this one
hurt so much was we had an american
bulldog those [ __ ] are strong
as [ __ ]
big he hated when we were in the pool
because he was so protective of us
so he thinks like we're drowning and
[ __ ] right so every time we were
swimming he'd just be barking running
around
running around like being all scared
like super anxious every once in a while
would jump
in but he couldn't swim so he'd just
jump right bottom
we'd have to go pick him up all the way
and [ __ ] but
our pool had this big ass ledge where
like you can sit and chill in the water
still
but not be in the whole pool right so i
was standing on it
and he was on the stairs right next to
it just barking barking
i just stepped back just enough so when
he closed his mouth on one of those
barks he bit me right on the back right
here
bro heard so bad i know to do i just ran
and jumped in the pool
and i'm in underwater my god like this
like [ __ ] i got out
i got out i'm just sitting there
screaming like [ __ ]
and he was such a sweet dog he came over
he's like licking my face like in my
face like
because he was like scared or something
[ __ ] and uh
but bro that only one tooth i had one
little mark
but that scar it was so deep that even
when it was like scarred up
for [ __ ] ever like if you just pushed
on it it [ __ ] hurt you know what that
you know what that means you gotta get
stitches
i know but she's like yeah i can put my
finger all the way in my
ass no it was such a small hole though
bro it was such a small hole on my back
but even when it healed like when you
press on the scar it [ __ ] hurts yeah
that means you need stitches yeah i was
like [ __ ] bro it was deep as hell
bro yeah i mean and i mean american
bulldogs if you don't know those types
of dogs they're big as [ __ ] strong as
a [ __ ]
people do some dumb [ __ ] when your kids
know man like i remember when uh my
parents got these cut cone knives y'all
remember cutco
bro my brother sells cocoa knives yeah
for like three weeks yeah so my parents
had uh cut go knives
and i remember watching uh those do you
remember something called the magic
blade
yeah i really they would have a
pineapple and they would cut that [ __ ]
in mid-air
so i guess what your boy did with some
cutco knives right so i had some cocoa
steak knives
and i was throwing up fruit in the house
before fruiting slicing up fruit right
well one of them because i was cutting
up so much fruit my hands got a little
slippery
and i juggled it it was just dripping
with you i tried to catch it
but it literally the butt of the knife
landed here and then the other part of
the knife went pop real quick
and i dropped it i was like [ __ ] and i
looked at it and you can still see it's
kind of like this meaty lump right here
this is where the knife just cut in
right to the right into the hand
and i remember looking at it i was like
oh that's just not that bad because
it doesn't start immediate like
immediately bleeding i didn't know it
takes a while
yeah and i was like it's not that bad
and then you bled out and then i was
like oh that's not that bad i was like
cool so i started cleaning up the fruit
and i was looking up behind me and
there's this trail of blood
throughout the whole [ __ ] house is
because my hand was bleeding like a
[ __ ]
but i was so scared of my parents
beating my [ __ ] ass i didn't tell but
i needed stitches for this thing
but all i did i remember that uh i just
kind of wrapped it up i told them i got
hurt from outside
whatever i just wrapped up for like a
month and this [ __ ] hurt for the longest
time
oh my god and it just became this huge
just like the cyst of a lump but
this thing it didn't heal correctly
because i was like this the whole time
because it hurt so bad because i was
trying to hold that meat together
well after it finally healed up i
remember this index finger couldn't
extend out all the way
because it was the way it healed up the
scar tissue
so it was like this for like a couple of
months and i never told my parents but
then one day i got so fed up with it i
just
grabbed my finger i yanked it up and i
popped like the scar tissue
and i finally was able to die bro open
up my hand after that [ __ ] i remember
one time i was i think it was uh i was
in sixth grade
and it was like the day before my
sister's prom from high school right
my buddy came over and he it was like i
think it was like
it was like may and it was still it was
like a really cold month i remember
because we had a pool in may yeah this
was this is a while ago because i
remember
caffeine bro capping i remember because
the pool was really cold and my buddy
was like let's go swim and i was like i
don't want to go swimming it's too
[ __ ] cold bro
so i remember we go swim and it's
freezing we were there for like two
seconds and i i
pushed off the wall and i guess the
light that was on the pool
was broken i sliced my foot
and as i'm like ah [ __ ] i look down
and it's in the blood everywhere so i
hop out
my my ankle is like hanging off bro it's
like it's like sliced up
clearly needs stitches and i'm like yo
like this is crazy i'm like freaking i'm
turning pale because i was losing a lot
of blood
so my dad goes all right we'll take care
of this and my mom was like we have to
take him to the hospital
my dad goes we're not going to the
hospital
what the [ __ ] this dude i i remember
this
he takes a box of band-aids like the
brown regular band-aids
he [ __ ] just puts all of them on
like like 45 and then he there's some
like chinese herb i forgot what it was
but i remember it was like it was like
brown
and it was like a powder nutmeg it was
so
good it was just cinnamon [ __ ] spice
yeah that's nothing gross all spices
this dude is pouring chinese five spices
on my [ __ ] window and you're just
pouring it on and then putting the
band-aids
and then continues to take duct tape
and wraps my ankle just the ankle that's
not even the whole foot
wraps it around and i'm like
there's a picture of my sister has to be
like in like she's getting
ready for the prom and i'm like pale
in the back just dying she's taking a
picture with me i have like
my stupid glasses on my stupid like
spiky hair everything's flat
but my hair is just spiky like this you
know
i'm like how did that heal up
thankfully it healed up fine yeah but
like my mom had to like treat my wounds
like every [ __ ] day
like we were the [ __ ] civil war bro
my dad did some crazy ass [ __ ] bro so
when we were younger we all three shared
a room i've said this before right
so but our room used to be dirty as [ __ ]
bro we never clean that [ __ ] right
but we used to fish a lot like so i love
fishing so we used to fish a lot
just one day someone put their tackle
box in like in the middle of our floor
bro
sticking out so so this is my foot i
know you guys can see this so this is
the hook and this is my foot
i just so happen to be close enough when
i started taking the step
it caught on my pinky but i didn't feel
it i
finished the step and then it pulled me
back so the [ __ ]
the thing went all the way into my
[ __ ] toe right now stop the story i
don't know
so i go and i'm like [ __ ] and like i'm
sitting there because it like
those hurt but they don't hurt that much
right but i'm like oh
[ __ ] bro and i'm telling my brother's
like dude this is deep
dude and we're sitting there trying to
take it out i'm like dude
i can't get it out so i go out to my dad
there's another hook on the other
side there's yeah there's two there's
[ __ ] so i go and i
and i tell my dad i'm like hey we might
have to go to the hospital
and he's like why and i show him my foot
it's like what the [ __ ] happened
i was like it was sticking out i [ __ ]
stepped through the guy so he brings him
to the bathroom he's like just wait
right here
he turns on hot water and he's like keep
your foot under this
so i have my foot under water for like
[ __ ] 15 minute
minutes until my foot's like a [ __ ]
raisin right
and then slowly just he went and got a
little razor blade
just slow little cuts little cuts little
cuts little cuts little cuts a little
cuts a little close
until it opened enough where he can just
pull off the rod and then we just put a
band-aid over my toe
wow dad is a surgeon bro bro my dad is
dr david
but that is something that's what [ __ ]
he goes hey that's legit though he goes
i actually know how to deal with this
i've done this multiple times
that's so genius i remember when we went
fishing and then when jason
chen oh bro pricked his finger i was
like
it was the first it was like we didn't
even take off yeah bro we were still
setting up the rods and [ __ ] i'm like
chasing him bro
bro he he pricked his finger and i was
like i'm done i don't know he's like
guys
you can't even tell when he has blood
loss because he's already pale as [ __ ]
he just looks like himself just sleepy
bro he's sitting there fishing like this
the whole time his one finger's just up
he's like this his big ass [ __ ]
tissues around his [ __ ] [ __ ] bro
fishing is hard man like the first time
i ever fished was with my
with my cousin joe and i remember uh
because i don't know how to fish but i
only saw [ __ ] on cartoons
so i remember i just whipped it back and
then it caught on to his shirt
dude that [ __ ] [ __ ] torah that was so
mad at me i was like brought it off
[ __ ] fish yeah we always grew up
hearing the story because we grow up
fishing right we
i love fishing to this day um
my i think it was my grandma my dad's
side uh
supposedly she was sitting there at a
park and she was just sitting down they
were enjoying a park
someone just so happened to be fishing
they [ __ ] threw the the rod back
caught her right here bro
that's it that's it bro this podcast is
over here it caught her around her
eyelid
and so they had to go to the hospital
and they had to say so for the rest of
life she's always look surprised
she's like if that happens to me i'm
fighting everybody bro yeah
i don't care if i'm getting my ass beat
dude we went fishing with my uncle and
his old girlfriend right she they had
kids right when we got to the lake bro
her the [ __ ] got stuck in her finger so
deep that they couldn't get it out
because some of the [ __ ] hooks they
have the normal hook and it's a sharp
one but they also have little
extra little extra sharp things in there
they have a little
lock in so like that's why it's so
[ __ ] hard to take it out of the fish
but that's also why the fish can't get
off of it right all the mackerel we had
to take the hooks off
oh my god dude or that one the one fat
mexican dude actually did it all the
time i know bro hey
he already knew that i was going to do
it so i just feel like excuse me he has
a mullet too now
he does asp
yeah he has a mullet now bro i just went
again fishing on my birth and
it was kind of whack in the sense of of
just of course when i decided to go
it was so slow we caught when we went
remember i caught
so much it was too much we were getting
annoyed with how much fish we were
actually catching because it was the
fish
so much [ __ ] fish right this time
first two hours we didn't even get a
[ __ ] bite
i was like [ __ ] bro come on for real and
then we asked them and they're like yeah
the past three days it's been
dead right so in total me and my homie
aaron caught
20. and i know people are like oh that
sounds like a lot but
from when we five hours of failure 20 is
[ __ ] nothing
we got 20 the first like hour yeah so
um we go home and of course the next day
they post on their instagram
bro just in one fish on the first trip
they caught over 100.
i was like of course bro the next
[ __ ] day right the next day
these [ __ ] are catching
something [ __ ] deeply checked [ __ ]
check the fish report
fishingport.com no they have all the
they have all the fish and all that yeah
they tell you when they stock the ocean
exactly well guys that wraps up this
episode of the genius brain podcast
it's a lot of [ __ ] random memories
popping up man it's weird how you don't
make it yeah you just don't remember
until somebody launches something
especially we're talking about people
getting hit and falling off cars yeah
it's like how do you forget what's so
big how do you forget
what made me remind that was like and
every time we tell her my friend's still
mad that's what made me [ __ ] remember
that [ __ ] i can't believe i
forgot about the girl breaking both of
her legs
316.
that song goes when she got married of
that song
she's like walking like this and [ __ ]
she's like yeah [ __ ] she's like oh
she's wearing
something your grandma cut off
she's so bad i told y'all
well guys you could catch genius brain
every thursdays and sundays you could
catch these guys on their instagrams you
got
nick at nick the ear and we got alice at
was it alex underscore
no it's just lift god g-o-d-d
lift god you always use hella [ __ ]
letters dude i said lift god with two
f's or one
two f's two g's all right sorry two f's
two ds baby
that's why my man bro it's gangster i
don't know that's how we grew up you put
two letters in everything i don't know
it makes it cooler with gods with a
dollar sign at the end yeah that's right
but we'll see you all next time
peace